SHOULD LET. ATKINS. BATES GOOD
THING I FELT. WE'RE JUST
BRADFORD CABALLERO JANE DOLLY
DODD THE RUSSELL GALGIANI
GLAZER GONZALEZ GROVE HERTZBERG
HILL WITH SO TITLE JACKSON
JONES LEYVA MCGUIRE MITCHELL
MONNING MORE LOCK RAIL NIELSEN.
PAN PORTANTINO ROTH RUBIO
SKINNER STERN STONE NUMBER WHY
CASKEY WIENER WILK. A QUORUM IS
PRESENT WITH THE MEMBERS AND
OUR GAS BEYOND THE RAIL AND IN
THE GALLERY PLEASE RISE WE'LL
BE LETTING PER THIS AFTERNOON
BY OUR CHAPLAIN SISTER MICHELLE
GORMAN AFTER WHICH PLEASE
REMAIN STANDING AS WILL BE LED
IN THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE TO
THE FLAG. BY SENATOR JEFF STONE.
LET US CENTER OURSELVES IN
GOD'S PRESENCE. AND FROM THE
RIDER LOUISE ERDRICH. WE ARE
NEVER SO POOR THOSE WE CANNOT
BLASTS ANOTHER HUMAN BEING ARE
WE. SO IT SAYS THAT EVERY EVIL
WHETHER MORAL OR MATERIAL
RESULTS AND GOODS YOU'LL SEE.
AND SO WE PRAY. IN THE NAME OF
ALL THAT IS WE COME TOGETHER.
IN THE NAME OF THE ELEMENTS OF
LIFE IN THE NAME OF THE SOIL
WATER AND AIR. IN THE NAME OF
ALL THAT IS WE COME. IN THE
NAME OF ALL THAT IS WE COME
TOGETHER. AND THE NAME OF THE
CHILDREN OF FOR. AND THE NAME
OF THE SPIRITS BREATHING AND
ALL THINGS. IN THE NAME OF ALL
THAT IS WE COME. SO MAY ALL WE
DO TODAY BE FOR THE HEALING OF
THE WORLD. MAY ALL WE DO TODAY
MEN'S ARE BROKEN WORLDS. MAY
ALL WE DO TODAY BRING BLESSING
ON THE EARTH. MAY ALL WE DO
TODAY BE FOR THE GOOD OF ALL A
MAN. COLLEAGUES PLEASE JOIN ME
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG
OF THE UNITED STATES WHEN OUR.
AND TO THE REPUBLIC FOR WHICH
IT STANDS ONE NATION UNDER GOD
INDIVISIBLE WITH LIBERTY AND
JUSTICE FOR ALL. MOVING TO
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR. CENTER
HERTZBERG. FOR INTRODUCTION.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO KINDLY
YOUR- MISTER PRESIDENT YOU KNOW.
THERE'S SO MANY GREAT
PRIVILEGES THAT EACH OF US HAVE.
IN FOLKS DO WE GET TO MEET. NEW
LEADERS OF THE EXCITING ELECTED
CHALLENGES AS RESULT OF SERVING
ON THIS IN THIS IS STEAMED BODY
AND TODAY IS ANOTHER ONE OF
THOSE DAYS. EARLIER THIS SUMMER
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS THAT
PROBABLY SOON SOME DAY WILL
SERVE HERE IN THIS AND OTHER
BODIES FROM ALL AROUND THE
STATE. HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
DEMONSTRATE THEIR TECHNOLOGICAL
PROWESS OF THE CALIFORNIA CYBER
INNOVATION CHALLENGE HELD IN
SENATOR JUAN THESE DISTRICT IN
SAN LUIS OBISPO. PARTICIPANTS
MEMBERS. WERE TASKED WITH THE
COLLABORATING AS DIGITAL
FORENSICS TEAMS IN ORDER SECURE
HEALTHCARE INFORMATION OF
MEDICAL RECORDS DEVICES
SOMETHING THAT THE CHAIR OF OUR
OUR JUDICIARY COMMITTEE IS
KEENLY AWARE OF. THESE
CHALLENGES THEY FACED REAL
WORLD SCENARIOS THE GOODS THAT
WERE COULD STRIKE AT ANY MOMENT
CYBERSECURITY AS WE HAVE
DISCUSSED MANY TIMES ON THIS
FLOOR. IS A GREAT CHALLENGES
OUR SOCIETY IS STILL COMING TO
GRIPS WITH. CAL POLY'S MANTRA
OF LEARNING BY DOING. WITH THIS
CHALLENGE SERVE TO PROPEL THE
SCHOOLS EFFORT TO EDUCATE
CALIFORNIANS AND HOW TO PROTECT
THE STATE FROM FUTURE CYBER
ATTACKS TO HANDS ON EXPERIENCE
TODAY THE DAY HERE ON THIS
FLOOR WE HONOR THE THREE
SCHOOLS IN THE COMPETITION THAT
PLACED IN FIRST SECOND THIRD AS
WELL AS VERY IMPORTANTLY A
SCHOOL FROM PARADISE CALIFORNIA
THAT SUFFERED THE HORRIBLE
TRAGEDY THAT THEY SUFFERED. SO
I START WITH ANNOUNCING TO
SCHOOLS BOTH OF WHOM ARE IN THE
COMMUNITIES THAT I REPRESENT IN
THE EIGHTEENTH SENATORIAL
DISTRICT. FIRST PLACE WINNER.
WAS NORTH HOLLYWOOD HIGH SCHOOL
THEY'RE HERE TODAY NORTH
HOLLYWOOD HIGH SCHOOL. HOW WILL
TURN OVER TO SENATOR CHIANG TO
ANNOUNCE THE SECOND PLACE
WINNERS. THANK YOU SO MUCH
SENATOR YOU KNOW I WAS REALLY
EXCITED TO HEAR THAT IT HAS TO
DO WITH MEDICAL DEVICES BECAUSE
ONE OF MY FIRST JOBS WAS TO
ANALYZE TELEPHONICALLY
TRANSMITTED EKG HE'S AND I WAS
ALSO PROJECT MANAGER OF A
HEALTH INFORMATION SYSTEMS
COMPANY SO. IT IS WITH GREAT
HONOR TO INTRODUCE THE TROY
TECH SUPPORT TEAM FROM TROY
HIGH SCHOOL IN FULLERTON%
CALIFORNIA THE RECENTLY TOOK
SECOND PLACE IN DIVISION ONE OF
THE CALIFORNIA CYBERSECURITY
INNOVATION CHALLENGES SUMMER
CAL POLY EARLIER THIS YEAR
TROY. HIGH SCHOOL ALSO NATIONAL
HONORS AT THE AIR FORCE
ASSOCIATIONS CYBER PATRIOT CAM
COMPETITIONS CONGRATULATIONS
CONGRATULATIONS. AND SENATORS
TO ADD TO THE CELEBRATION FROM
THE SENATE EIGHTEEN SENATORIAL
DISTRICT IS THE GRANADA HILLS
THE GRANADA HILLS CHARTER HIGH
SCHOOL TEAM TAKING THIRD PLACE
IN THE COMPETITION. LET'S GIVE
A ROUND OF APPLAUSE. AGAIN THE
MIDDLE. NUMBER I SAN
. AND ONE
MORE. THANKS EVERYBODY. WHILE
WE'RE WAITING FOR OUR STUDENTS
TO DISEMBARK THE FLOOR WHEN I
RECOGNIZE OUR FORMER COLLEAGUE
FROM THE SAN FERNANDO VALLEY
SENATOR FRAN PAVLEY. THE CARD.
AT CENTER PATHWAYS GIFT A
GETTING GUEST TODAY IS BETH
GARDNER WHO HAS A NEW GROUND
POLLUTION WHICH I KNOW WE'RE
ALL CONCERNED ABOUT SO MS
GARDNER. COREY OKAY YOU'RE BACK
THERE. CONTINUING WITH
PRIVILEGES THE FLOOR. I WAS.
CENTER NIELSEN FOR WHAT PURPOSE.
THE SPREAD LAYS DOWN THE SENATE
I'D LIKE TO INTRODUCE YOU CHIEF
CHARTER SCHOOL. FOLKS HERE THAT
ARE. HAD THE THERE THERE ARE
GREAT SUCCESS THEMSELVES AND
THIS IS A COMMUNITY THAT YOU
ARE. VERY FAMILIAR WITH. I'M
MORE THAN AND. AND WHAT IS
SIGNIFICANT. IS THAT IN SUCH A
CHALLENGE AREA. THE THESE YOU'D
HAVE HAD TO CONTEND WITH. THEY
DIDN'T SHRINK. FROM THEIR
DUTIES AND THEIR DREAMS THAT
THEY PURSUED IT WITH FULL VIGOR.
THE COMEBACK KIDS. I WANT TO
CONGRATULATE YOU AND PRESENT
YOU WITH THE RESOLUTION
TECHNOLOGY YOUR ACHIEVEMENT
.
CONTINUING WITH THE PRIVILEGES
OF THE FLOOR SENATOR HERTZBERG
ON FILE ITEM FORTY ONE AT HIS
DESK CENTER HERTZBERG BECAUSE I
AM SKEWS ME SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SENATE RESOLUTION FIFTY
THREE BY SENATOR HERTZBERG
RELATIVE TO CALIFORNIA NATIVE
AMERICAN DAY AND THE CALIFORNIA
INDIAN CULTURE. CULTURAL
AWARENESS CONFERENCE CENTER
HERTZBERG THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER PRESIDENT TOUGH. I RISE
TODAY TO JOIN IN A PRESENTATION
THAT OCCURRED JUST MOMENTS AGO
IN THE OTHER HOUSE WITH OUR
ESTEEMED COLLEAGUE JAMES RIBOSE
WHO WOULD REDUCE THE PERIL
MEASURE. AS YOU KNOW MEMBERS
MISTER RAMOS WAS IMMEDIATE
PRESS PRESIDENT A PAST CHAIRMAN
EXCUSE ME OF THE SAN MANUEL
BAND. OF MISSION INDIANS. I
WOULD LIKE TO ECHO IS COMMENTS
OF MISTER RAMOS AND RECOGNIZING
GOVERNOR NEWSOME'S RECENT
EXECUTIVE ORDER. WHICH ISSUED
AN APOLOGY TO THE NATIVE
AMERICAN COMMUNITY OF
CALIFORNIA FOR A STATE
HISTORICAL WRONGDOINGS AGAINST
IT OF AMERICANS. MEMBERS YOUR
STATE IS RELATIVELY YOUNG WHEN
IT COMES TO OUR OFFICIAL
STATEHOOD. WE ARE FAMILIAR WITH
THE DEEP AND STORIED HISTORY
THAT BEGUN BEFORE MANY OF OUR
PREDECESSORS ARRIVED HERE TODAY.
CALIFORNIA IS HOME TO MORE
FEDERALLY RECOGNIZED NATIVE
AMERICAN TRIBES IN ANY OTHER
STATE IN THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA THE CONTRIBUTION OF
NATIVE AMERICANS NATIVE PEOPLES
OF CALIFORNIA HAVE SHAPE THE
COURSE OF THE STATE THROUGHOUT
A VERY LONG HISTORY. WHICH
PREDATES ANY INCORPORATION. IT
IS SO IMPORTANT THAT WE
CONTINUE TO CELEBRATE THIS
CULTURAL HERITAGE AND KEEP THE
LEGACY OF OUR NATIVE AMERICAN
PEOPLE'S ALIVE. SOME YEARS AGO
I WAS PROUD TO ESTABLISH THE
SEALS COMMISSION. SALES
COMMISSION WHICH PLACE TWO
SEALS AT THE FOOT OF THE WEST
STEPS OF THE CAPITOL ONE
CELEBRATING OUR SPANISH MEXICAN
HERE IT IS UP TO CHEN IS THREE
AND THE OTHER CELEBRATING FORTY
GENERATIONS OF NATIVE AMERICANS
IN CALIFORNIA. THE SEALS ARE
THERE TO REMIND US. THE
CALIFORNIA'S FUTURE MEMBERS
LIES IN OUR CONTINUED STRENGTH
OF OUR DIVERSITY AND A CLEAR
UNDERSTANDING OF OUR PAST. BILL
THE CELEBRATE OUR HISTORY THE
SEALS ARE INDEED A TESTAMENT TO
THE CULTURAL HERITAGE THAT IS
VERY MUCH STILL ALIVE AND
ACTIVE IN CALIFORNIA TODAY. AND
SO WITH THE SPIRIT WE HAVE
DESIGNATED BY THIS MEASURE THE
FOURTH FRIDAY OF EVERY
SEPTEMBER AS CALIFORNIA NATIVE
AMERICAN DAY. TO CELEBRATE BY
TRIBES IN COMMUNITIES TO BE
CELEBRATED EXCUSE ME BY TRIED
TO COMMITTEES ACROSS THE STATE.
SR FIFTY THREE ESTABLISHES
SEPTEMBER TWENTY SEVENTH TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN IS THE DAY
THAT WE WILL RECOGNIZE
CALIFORNIA NATIVE AMERICAN DAY
THIS YEAR. SR FIFTY THREE ALSO
HIGHLIGHTS THE CALIFORNIA
INDIAN CULTURAL AWARENESS
CONFERENCE WHICH WILL BE HELD
CONCURRENTLY WITH CALIFORNIA'S
NATIVE AMERICAN DAY CONFERENCE
WILL PROVIDE MEMBERS. WITH
EDUCATORS IN WITH NEW RESOURCES
REGARDING THE RICH AND VERY THE
LIVES OF CALIFORNIA INDIAN
NATIONS THAT WE CONTINUE TO
TEACH EACH GENERATION AS WE GO
FORWARD THE CHILDREN OF
CALIFORNIA OF ALL BACKGROUNDS
AND CULTURES THE IMPORTANCE OF
THEIR CONTRIBUTION I
RESPECTFULLY MEMBERS ASK YOUR
RIVAL. THANK YOU CENTER HUESO.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT I
JUST WANTED TO RISE ON BEHALF
OF SR FIFTY THREE IS A VERY
IMPORTANT ELEMENT OF CALIFORNIA
AS A SOCIETY AND OUR HISTORY
RECENTLY IN MY DISTRICT AN
ARCHAEOLOGICAL DIG DISCOVERED.
HE GOT AYE AYE. OF EVIDENCE OF
HUMAN ACTIVITY THIRTY THOUSAND
YEARS AGO. AND IF YOU THINK OF
WHEN WE OFTEN TO THINK OF THE
OF THE THEORIES OF PEOPLE
COMING OVER THE BERING STRAIT
TO POPULATE CALIFORNIA THIS
THIS PREDATES THAT BY TWENTY
THOUSAND YEARS SO WE HAD PEOPLE
LIVING HERE IN CALIFORNIA AND
MY GUESS BUT THEY WERE THE
NATIVE AMERICAN TRIBES THAT ARE
SOME OF WHICH STILL EXIST IN
CALIFORNIA. AND AUTHORS BUT NO
LONGER EXIST A TRIBE IN THE
MODOC AREA KNOWN AS THE YA HE
NO LONGER EXIST WHY BECAUSE
THEY WERE ELIMINATED BECAUSE OF
GENOCIDE. WHEN GENOCIDE IS PART
OF OUR HISTORY PART OF OUR
NATION'S HISTORY PART OF
CALIFORNIA'S HISTORY. AND
BECAUSE OF THAT GENOCIDE THERE
ARE NO OTHER CULTURES KNOW THE
PEOPLE. IN IN AMERICAN IN
CALIFORNIA THAT WERE THE
VICTIMS OF GENOCIDE HONOR
NATIVE SOIL OTHER THAN THE
NATIVES OF THE SOIL THE NATIVE
AMERICANS. WHO STILL. ARE ARE
IN A STATE OF SUFFERING IN OUR
STATE THEY ARE POSSESS SOME OF
THE HIGHEST UNEMPLOYMENT RATES
IN THE STATE SOME OF THE
HIGHEST. DROP OUT RATES FROM
HIGH SCHOOL SOME OF THE HIGHEST
POVERTY RATES THE NATIVE
AMERICANS. OR OR SOME OF THE
ARE OR IT'S SOME OF THE PEOPLE
ARE STATE THAT ARE STRUGGLING
THE MOST THE MOST THREE PART OF
THIS ECONOMY AND STILL
STRUGGLING FROM YEARS OF
ATTEMPTED GENOCIDE AND YEARS OF
INEQUALITY IN YEARS OF
PERSECUTION. SO THIS IS A VERY
IMPORTANT MEASURE I'M I'M I'M
VERY PROUD TO BE A. A PART OF
THE SENATE RECOGNIZING OR OR
NATIVE CULTURES PEOPLE THAT
HAVE MADE THE STATE AS RICH AS
IT IS BUT ALSO IT'S A REMINDER
TO THIS LEGISLATURE AND THE
PEOPLE OF THE STATE THAT WE
HAVE MUCH MANY SINCE TO ATONE
FOR. AS AS THE INHERITORS OF
OUR STATE AS THE LEADERS OF THE
STATE. FIGHTING TO. CREATE MORE
QUALITY IN THE STATE BUT LET'S
NOT FORGET OUR NATIVE AMERICAN
BROTHERS THAT ARE STILL
STRUGGLING TODAY. IN THIS VERY
STATE THAT WE LOVE SO MUCH
PLEASE SUPPORT US ARE FIFTY
THREE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER PRESIDENT THANK YOU
CENTER HUESO CENTER GLAZER.
THANK YOU ARE MISTER PRESIDENT
MEMBERS I THANK THE SENATOR
FROM THE SAN FERNANDO VALLEY
FOR BRING THIS IMPORTANT
RESOLUTION TO US TODAY AND- I'M
HAPPY TO SUPPORT IT BUT- I DO
FEEL LIKE THIS CONVERSATION
THAT WE DID WE NEED TO HAVE
EVEN MORE CONVERSATION ABOUT
THE- TREATMENT OF NATIVE
AMERICANS IN OUR HISTORY I
APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR'S
LEADERSHIP. AND APOLOGIZING FOR
ACTIONS OF THE- STATE AGAINST
OUR- BROTHERS AND SISTERS BUT I
THINK THAT THERE'S SO MUCH MORE
THAT WE SHOULD DO. IN TERMS OF
UNDERSTANDING THE REPREHENSIBLE
CONDUCT OF OUR STATE LEADERS
YES OUR STATE LEADERS PEOPLE.
WHO MADE SOME VERY BAD CHOICES
IN OUR HISTORY HOPE WE CAN
CONTINUE IT WAY BEYOND THE
RESOLUTION THAT'S BEFORE US
TODAY WHICH I'M HAPPY TO
SUPPORT. THANK YOU SIR SENATOR
STERN. THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT I RISE ON. PERSONALLY
AS WELL AS ON BEHALF OF THE
JEWISH CAUCUS HISTORY MATTERS.
TELL THE TRUTH ABOUT HISTORY
MATTERS. I WAS A TEACHER MY
PAST LIFE AND- WHEN YOU LOOK
BACK INTO THE HISTORY BOOKS.
MOST YOUNG PEOPLE LEARN IN
FOURTEEN NINETY TWO COLUMBUS
SAILED THE OCEAN BLUE AND ALL
IS WELL AFTER THAT IN FACT
THAT'S NOT THE CASE. AND I
THINK. THIS MUCH CELEBRATION IS
WE HAVE TO DO AROUND THIS
IMPORTANT DAY. CELEBRATIONS NOT
ENOUGH THERE NEEDS TO BE
RECTIFICATION. AND UNTIL WE
CHANGE. THE WAY WE TEACH YOUNG
PEOPLE IN THIS STATE. AND
STARTING WITH OUR OWN HOLIDAYS
AND WHAT WE RECOGNIZE AS THE
TRUTH OF HISTORY. THESE
INJUSTICES WILL STILL NOT BE
RECTIFIED. AND I WOULD HOPE
PERHAPS IN FUTURE YEARS WHEN WE
PASSED SIMILAR RESOLUTIONS IN
FACT EVEN SOME OF THE
ICONOGRAPHY HAVE THIS BUILDING
STARTS TO SHIFT AND RECOGNIZE
OUR HISTORY. I THINK OUT TO
THAT ROTUNDA. WITH COLUMBUS.
SITTING THERE BESTOWING QUEEN
ISABELLA AND THE CELEBRATIONS
THAT ARE INHERENT IN THAT
RECOGNITION AT THE CENTER PIECE
OF THIS CAPITAL. I THINK.
THAT'S CULTURE PROBABLY BELONGS
MORE APPROPRIATELY IN A MUSEUM.
BUT NOT AS A PLACE OF HISTORY.
AND SO I HOPE TO WORK WITH OUR
BROTHERS AND SISTERS NOT JUST
IN THE NATIVE AMERICAN
COMMUNITY BUT ACROSS THE STATE
ACROSS CULTURES ACROSS THE
JEWISH CAUCUS AND SO MANY OTHER
CRITICAL STAKEHOLDERS IN THIS
STATE ARE TO TELL A NEW STORY.
TO TELL THE TRUTH ABOUT OUR
HISTORY. RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL
THANK YOU CENTER CENTER
ARCHULETA. THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT. I TO RISE IN SUPPORT
OF SRFIFTY THREE AND I BRING
RECOGNITION TO THE MANY NATIVE
AMERICANS WHO SERVED. OUR GREAT
NATION AND ARMED FORCES AND OF
COURSE WHEN YOU THINK OF THE
VETERANS WHO SERVED. IN WORLD
WAR TWO YOU HAVE TO THINK OF
THE CODE TALKERS NAVAJO. CODE
TALKERS AS THEY WERE TOLD THAT
THEY WERE ABLE TO COMMUNICATE
AMONG THEMSELVES. THAT SAVE.
THOUSANDS UPON THOUSANDS OF
AMERICAN LIVES ENABLE G. BUT-
TARA IN ALL THE PLACES IN THE
SOUTH PACIFIC. WERE MARINES
WERE FIGHTING EVERY SINGLE DAY
LOSING THEIR LIVES. FOR OUR
COUNTRY BUT HAD IT NOT BEEN FOR
THE NAVAJO TRIBESMEN THAT WERE
THERE IN BACK THEN THAT'S WHAT
THEY WERE REFERRED TO AS
TRIBESMEN BUT THEY WERE
REFERRED TO IN OUR EYES AS A
VETERAN THAT I AM. AS HEROES
AND THEY PROTECTED THE CODE THE
SECRET CODES THAT WERE
COMMUNICATED FROM BACK AND
FORTH FROM UNIT TO UNIT. AND
THE JAPANESE WERE NOT ABLE TO
BREAK THAT CODE. AND AS YOU'VE
ALL SEEN AND WATCHING THE SEE
THE BEAUTIFUL MONUMENT WITH THE
MARINES ARE HOSTING THE FLAG
ABOVE. MONTEIRO BOCCE IN IN A
REGINA ANYONE OF A NATIVE
AMERICAN. SO YOU CAN IMAGINE
THE CONTRIBUTION THAT'S BEEN
MADE BY THE NATIVE AMERICANS IN
THIS COUNTRY AND TODAY WE
RECOGNIZE YOU AS WE SHOULD
RECOGNIZE YOU EVERY SINGLE DAY
FOR YOUR CONTRIBUTIONS YOU
GIVEN TO US THE MILITARY AND
LAW ENFORCEMENT ALL WALKS OF
LIFE. AND WE THANK YOU FOR THIS
DAY AND THIS IS WHY SUPPORT
THIS BILL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SIR SENATOR PAN. THANK YOU OF
THIS PRESIDENT CENTERS I TO
RISE IN STRONG SUPPORT THIS
RESOLUTION WHAT THANK MY GOOD
FRIEND FROM LOS ANGELES FOR
BRING THIS FORWARD THINK IT'S
SO IMPORTANT THAT WE DO
REMEMBER AT THE HISTORY OF OUR-
NATIVE AMERICAN. BROTHERS AND
SISTERS WHO ACTUALLY HAVE WERE
LIVING ON THIS CONTINENT. FOR
MILLENNIA AND I THINK WHEN WE
OFTENTIMES WE TALK OF THE
HISTORY CALIFORNIA. WE DON'T
THINK THE FACT THAT ACTUALLY
MOST OF HISTORY CALIFORNIA.
ACTUALLY EXISTED FOR THE COMING
OF PEOPLE FROM OTHER PARTS OF
THE WORLD TO THIS WONDERFUL
LAND AND SO I APPRECIATE THAT
WERE RECOGNIZING THIS IS
RESOLUTION I ALSO WANT TO
THANKS RIGHT NOW IN THE PAST
BUDGET BUDGETS WE ARE ALSO
GOING TO BE ESTABLISHING A
NAME. A MUSEUM WHICH WILL
HOPEFULLY ALSO BE AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA INSTITUTE PARTICULAR
USED TO LEARN MORE HEALTH IS
WELCOME CORPORATION THIS
INFORMATION INTO OUR CURRICULA
BECAUSE IT'S SO IMPORTANT THAT
ARE THAT CALIFORNIANS
UNDERSTAND OUR HISTORY GOES
BACK TO THE NAY AMERICAN.
CULTURES AND CIVILIZATIONS ARE
HERE FOR MILLENNIA AND THEY
HAVE A PROUD HISTORY AND THAT
HISTORY NEEDS REMEMBER AND WE
ALSO NEED TO KNOW REMEMBER THE
ATROCITIES OUR UNFORTUNATELY
EXPECTED ON THEM AS WELL AND
MORE RECENT HISTORY AND WHAT WE
NEED TO DO TO RESURRECT. AND
BRING BACK PEOPLES WHO HAVE
BEEN IN THIS STATE FOR SO LONG
SO AGAIN I STAND SUPPORTERS
RESOLUTION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
CENTER CENTER SKINNER. THANK
YOU I'M MATTER MISTER PRESIDENT
AND MEMBERS I ALSO STAND IN
SUPPORT OF SR FIFTY THREE. AND
SOME OF YOU MAY AS. READ THE
NEW YORK SUNDAY TIMES ON THIS
LATEST ISSUE. THE SUNDAY
MAGAZINE THIS WAS YESTERDAY
FEATURED. THE US IS HISTORY ON
SLAVERY. AND IT PARTICULARLY
MARKED. SIXTEEN NINETEEN
FIFTEEN NINETEEN FOURTEEN
NINETEEN SIXTY NINETEEN I'M
SORRY RIGHT . AS YOU'RE
RIGHT FOURTEEN NINETY TWO IS
COLUMBUS SIXTEEN NINETEEN AS
WHAT THEY FELT WAS THE FOUNDING
OF THIS COUNTRY VERSES OUR
DECLARATION OF INDEPENDENCE AND
THE REASON THAT THE FOCUS WAS
ON SIXTEEN NINETEEN IN AUGUST
ACTUALLY IT WAS THE FIRST SLAVE
SHIP. THAT HIT THE UNITED
STATES OR THE BLAND WE NOW CALL.
AND THE ARTICLES THEY'RE
THEY'RE VERY MOVING BUT THE
THERE'S MUCH IN IT. ABOUT THE.
LEGACY OF VIOLENCE THAT OUR
COUNTRY STILL SUFFERS UNDER.
AND I WAS STRUCK AGAIN BY IT
TODAY. WITH THE SIGNING OF OUR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER SPILLED
GOVERNOR NEWSOME SIGNING AROUND
ARE CHANGING IN THE USE OF
DEADLY FORCE AND WE HAVE WE ARE
VERY VIOLENT COUNTRY. AND WE
OFTEN IS WORK WHY WHY ARE WE
WHY DO WE HAVE MORE MASS
SHOOTINGS WHY DO WE HAVE MORE
GUN VIOLENCE WHY DO WE HAVE SO
MUCH OF THIS VIOLENCE SO
IMBEDDED IN THE U. S. COMPARED
TO ALMOST EVERY OTHER. ECONOMY
OF OUR OF OUR CLAPPED AND DE
THE WHOLE FOCUS OF THIS
MAGAZINE IS AROUND SLAVERY AS
ONE EXPLANATION IN IT'S A
SIGNIFICANT EXPLANATION BUT I
THINK THAT WE HAVE TO ALSO
INCLUDE OUR GENOCIDE. OF NATIVE
AMERICANS IN THAT. IT IS
EQUALLY AS VIOLENT OF HISTORY
WHERE WE LITERALLY. MADE IT
LEGAL TWO AND GAVE REWARDS.
JUST AS WE GAVE REWARDS AND
MADE IT LEGAL TO KILL ESCAPED
SLAVES WE GAVE REWARDS AND MADE
IT LEGAL TO KILL NATIVE
AMERICANS. AND WE ASSISTED OUR
OWN GOVERNMENT ARMY PROVIDED
NATIVE AMERICANS WITH A SMALL
POX INFECTED BLANKETS FOR
EXAMPLE. SO I THINK THAT WE CAN
NEVER STOP REMINDING OURSELVES
OF THESE. LEGACIES AND HOW THEY
STILL IMPACT NOT ONLY NATIVE
CALIFORNIANS TO NATIVE
AMERICANS BUT ALL OF US AND
EVERYTHING IN OUR CULTURE. I
WAS VERY PROUD IN THE LAST YEAR
THAT I SERVED IN THE BERKELEY
CITY COUNCIL WHICH WAS NINETEEN
NINETY TWO AND IT WAS THE SEX
QUINN CINDY EISNER PRONOUNCES
WORDS RIGHT BUT WAS THE FIVE
HUNDRED YEAR ANNIVERSARY OF
WHEN COLUMBUS SHOWED UP ON OUR
SHORES. AND OF COURSE WE NOW
UNDERSTAND THE COLUMBUS WAS NOT
THE FIRST AT ALL TO BE HERE.
AND THERE WAS A GROUP OF NATIVE
AMERICANS WHO APPROACHED ME AND
ASKED ME TO SEE WHETHER.
BERKELEY WOULD BE WILLING TO
CALL THAT DAY INDIGENOUS PEOPLE
STAY. SO I CARRIED THAT.
ORDINANCE IT WAS THE FIRST
ORDINANCE ADOPTED IN THE U. S.
BERKLEE HAS HONORED INDIGENOUS
PEOPLES DAY OR WHAT WAS
COLUMBUS DAY. SINCE THAT TIME.
AND WE HAVE HAD AN ALL TRIBES
POWER WELL ON THAT WEEKEND.
EVERY WEEKEND SINCE AND WE WILL
HAVE ANOTHER IN OCTOBER COMING
UP THIS YEAR. SO I VERY PROUD
TO STAND IN SUPPORT OF THIS
RESOLUTION AND VERY VERY. HAPPY
YOU'RE HAPPY IS WRONG WORD BUT-
HOW IMPORTANT IT IS FOR US TO
THINK ABOUT WHAT THESE LEGACIES
ARE AND THE FACT THAT THEY
DIDN'T JUST IMPACTS SOMEONE
IMPACT US TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR SEEING NO
FURTHER DEBATE OR DISCUSSION.
I'M SORRY CENTER GROWTH. THANK
YOU MISTER PRESIDENT I TO RISE
IN SUPPORT OF AND THE S. HERE
FOR US FIFTY THREE AND I
APPRECIATE ALL MY COLLEAGUES
COMMENTS ON THE OTHER SIDE OF
THE AISLE BUT I'D ALSO LIKE TO
MAKE SURE THAT AS WE
PARTICIPATE IN GO US GOING
FORWARD PROCESS AND I WAS
READING THE RESOLUTION AND IT
SAYS THAT THE TRIBAL COUNCILS
IN INDIVIDUALS FROM DIFFERENT
TRIBES. AND COUNCILS WILL BE
ABLE TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
EDUCATION CURRICULUM ITS AIR AS
WE FOCUS ON THE PAST SO THAT WE
DON'T EVER REPEAT IT LET'S ALSO
FOCUS ON THE FUTURE AND
RECOGNIZE THAT WHEN YOU HAVE A
FEDERAL RECOGNIZED TRIBE AND
THEY HAVE DESIGNATED LAND SET
ASIDE BY THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
THAT THAT LAND IS TRULY A
SOVEREIGN NATION WHICH OPERATES
WITHIN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
AND THE OUT LANDS NEEDS AND
THOSE SOVEREIGN NATIONS NEED TO
BE ABLE TO MAKE THEIR OWN RULES
AND FORTY. OVER THAT LAND IN
THEIR RESOURCES WITHOUT
INTERFERENCE FROM THE STATE
GOVERNMENT AND I WOULD ASK YOU
TO EDUCATE PEOPLE WHEN THEY
READ THIS CREEK LIMóN STUDENTS
UNDERSTAND AS THEY GROW UP AND
THEY READ THROUGH THIS AT THE
UNDERSTAND THE HISTORY THAT'S
VITALLY IMPORTANT BUT ALSO
UNDERSTAND MOVING FORWARD WHAT
NEEDS TO BE DONE SO THAT TO
FIBER COMMUNITIES CONTINUE TO
THRIVE IN OUR TRIBAL REGIONS SO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I'M AN
HONOR TO SUPPORT THIS
RESOLUTION. THANK YOU CENTER
GROVE. NOW SEE NOTE FURTHER
DEBATER DISCUSSION CENTER
HERTZBERG YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK
YOU MISTER PRESIDENT THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES FOR YOUR- SUPPORTIVE
COMMENTS WITH RESPECT TO THIS
RESOLUTION ARM I THINK IT IS
ABOUT HISTORY IT'S ABOUT
RESPECT. AND ON A PERSONAL
LEVEL YOU KNOW I LIVED IN A
FAMILY WHERE WE WERE DEEPLY
INVOLVED WITH MANY OF THE
ISSUES OF THE LAST FOUR THIRTY
OR FORTY YEARS FROM FLORIDA
THERE IS ON A TO HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. WHEN UNEMPLOYMENT
ON RESERVATIONS WERE CERTAIN TO
TRIBAL MEMBERS WERE PUSHED UP
IN VALLEY'S IN PLACES THAT AT
THE TIME WERE DEEMED TO BE
DESIRABLE AND EMPLOYMENT WAS
MORE THAN EIGHTY. UNEMPLOYMENT
WAS MORE THAN 80% AND THEY WERE
GREAT CIVIL RIGHTS ARE. FIGHTS
AND I WAS FORTUNATE TO BE THE
SON OF A CIVIL RIGHTS.
CONSTITUTIONAL LAWYER WHO
FOUGHT THOSE FIGHTS AND TAUGHT
ME THAT LEVEL OF RESPECT WHICH
INFORMS MY DECISION IMPORTANCE
BEHIND THIS RESOLUTION TODAY I
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS
IMPORTANT MEASURE. THANK YOU
CENTER HERTZBERG MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN. HI ARCHULETA I ATKINS I
BATES I BILL I PORGES I
BRADFORD. I CAL YELLOW I CHIANG
I DALY. I DODD I THEIR ALSO AYE
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER. BY
GONZALEZ I GROWTH. I HERTZBERG
AYE HILL AYE HUESO HI TITLE BY
JACKSON I JONES. I LEYVA AYE
MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL BY MONEY
I'M MORE LOCK I'M REAL. AYE
NIELSEN AYE PAN AYE PORTANTINO
BY ROTH I RUBIO I SKINNER. I
STERN AYE STONE AYE AMBERG. OUR
COUNTY BY WINNER BY WILK HI I.
OKAY ICE FORTY KNOWS NO
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED AND THE
MAJORITY LEADER FOR PURPOSES OF
INTRODUCTION PLEASE PROCEED
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
PRESIDENT WITH REGARD SR FIFTY
THREE WE ARE SO PRIVILEGE TODAY.
YOU HAVE THE A NUMBER OF
MEMBERS OF THE NEWLY FORMED
CALIFORNIA TRIBAL CHAIR PERSONS
ASSOCIATION HERE TODAY CHAIRMAN
RAMOS FROM THE OTHER HOUSE A
PRESENTED A JOINT RESOLUTION.
WHICH FROM BOTH HOUSES AND SO
THEY HAVE BEEN HERE TODAY AND
SO IF I COULD JUST BRIEFLY
INTRODUCE WHO WE HAVE HERE FROM
THE RING CONN BAND TO LISTEN
YOU INDIANS SHERMAN BOWL WAS AT
A GERMAN. ALSO THE VICE
CHAIRMAN OF THE CODE YOU VALLEY
BAND OF POMO INDIANS MICHAEL
HUNTER MICHAEL. THE TREASURE OF
THE TRINIDAD RANCHERIA GARTH
SUB BURKE. BURGER STICKING
TOGETHER AND ALSO A COUNCIL
MEMBER FROM ELK VALLEY
RANCHERIA DEAL MILLER IF YOU
GET ALL GIVE THEM A WARM SENATE
WELCOME WE APPRECIATE IT THANK
YOU
. FOR PURPOSES OF
INTRODUCTION SENATOR DALLY.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT BUT
HAVE THE MEMBERS ATTENTION FOR
A MOMENT. I EVERY YEAR FOR
THOSE OF YOU WHO SERVED IN THE
ASSEMBLY WITH ME BRING DOWN A
TRUCKLOAD OF PEACHES AND. THIS
WEDNESDAY I WILL BE IN THE
BASEMENT WITH A TRUCKLOAD OF
PEACHES AND I WANT TO ENCOURAGE
YOU FROM. TEN TO TEN THIRTY IS
FOR MEMBERS FIRST. SO YOU NEED
TO GET THERE AND GET A BAG OF
PEACHES THEY'RE BEING PICKED AS
WE SPEAK RIGHT NOW AND I KNOW
THOSE WHO SERVE IN THE
ASSEMBLY. ALWAYS ENJOYED A MY
NO THE SITTER FROM GARDENIA IS
HAD THEM BEFORE AND THE SENATOR
FROM BERKELEY SO PLEASE JOIN ME
IN THE BASEMENT FROM TEN TO TEN
THIRTY ON WEDNESDAY. AND I HAVE
FIFTY LUGS SO WE'LL BECAUSE
WHEN AS WELL FROM TEN THIRTY.
UNTIL THEY'RE GONE THE STAFF IS
AVAILABLE TO COME DOWN YOUR
STAFF AND THE PEOPLE WHO DO THE
HEAVY LIFTING THIS BUILDING CAN
GET SOME PEACHES AS WELL SO I.
WOULD LIKE FOR YOU TO COME DOWN
AND ENJOY THE PEACHES FROM MY
DISTRICT. THANK YOU SENATOR.
FOR PERSEVERE DIRECTION SENATOR
PAN THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
IT'S MY PLEASURE TO INTRODUCE
TO YOU UNITED AG A MULTI
COMMODITY MEMBER OWNED
AGRICULTURE ASSOCIATION
DEDICATED TO PROVIDING
INNOVATIVE EMPLOYEE HEALTH
BENEFITS SOLUTIONS TO ALL
CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURE
COMMUNITY UP IN THE GALLERY
THANK YOU. WHAT THEM WITH THEM
TODAY OR TO THEIR SPONSORED
LEADERSHIP GROUPS THE WOMEN AG
LEADERSHIP ACADEMY AND THE
EMERGING LEADERS ACADEMY CLASS.
BOTH SELECT GROUPS OF
AGRICULTURAL PROFESSIONALS ARE
HERE TODAY TO EXPAND THEIR
KNOWLEDGE OF PUBLIC POLICY THE
PUBLIC POLICY PROCESS IN THE
FIND AVENUES WHERE THEY CAN
CONTRIBUTE IN WAYS THAT BENEFIT
SOCIETY SO PLEASE JOIN ME IN
WELCOMING THESE TWO GROUPS OF
CAPITAL. WELCOME TO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE.
THERE'S CENTER SKINNER FOR
PURPOSES OF INTRODUCTION. I'M
STANDING OVER HERE MISTER
PRESIDENT MEMBERS BECAUSE MY
GUESTS ARE OVER HERE IN THE
GALLERY IT'S MY PRIVILEGE TO BE
ABLE TO INTRODUCE A GUEST WAS A
PIVOTAL COMMUNITY ADVOCATE IN
SENATE-DISTRICT NINE AS WELL AS
A FORMER LEAD STAFF PERSON IN
MY SENATE OFFICE TASHA HENNEMAN.
HAS A BACHELORS FROM CSU CHICO
A MASTERS IN PUBLIC
ADMINISTRATION FROM HAYWARD A
MASTER'S IN EDUCATIONAL
LEADERSHIP AND EARLY CHILDHOOD
DEVELOPMENT FROM MILLS AS WELL
AS HER DOCTORATE IN EDUCATION.
IN EARLY EDUCATION. CHILDHOOD
DEVELOPMENT FROM MILLS COLLEGE
SHE WAS AN AVID BASKETBALL
PLAYER WHO STILL HOLD SEVERAL
RECORDS AT BERKELEY HIGH IN
CHICO STATE AND BEFORE SHE
WORKED IN FOR THE SENATE SHE
WAS THE EARLY CHILDHOOD
CONSULTANT TO THE MAYOR'S
OFFICE OF THE CITY OF BERKLEY
SHE WAS THE PARENT SERVICES
MANAGER AT BANANAS THE FIRST
CHILD CARE. RESOURCE AND
REFERRAL AGENCY IN CALIFORNIA
HE WAS THE PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT COORDINATOR FOR
FIRST FIVE ALAMEDA COUNTY AND
IS NOW AN ADJUNCT FACULTY
INSTRUCTOR AT MILLS COLLEGE
TOUCHES JOINED IN THE GALLERY
BY HER FAMILY HER SISTER HER
DAUGHTER IN OR SIGN IN OR SIGN
HOPES TO FOLLOW HIS MOTHER'S
FOOTSTEPS. AS A CHAMPION
BASKETBALL PLAYER. TASHA HAD.
AND MISSED RISEN MEMBERS IF YOU
DON'T MIND I ALSO HAVE THREE
OTHER INTRODUCTIONS I WANTED TO
DO SOME DISTRICT. SANTERIA
SHAVERS WHO IS. I SHE IS AT
SKYLINE HIGH SCHOOL IN OAKLAND
CHEN MY YOUNG WHO IS MERE MONTY
HIGH SCHOOL IN OAKLAND IN A
RENDON'S SORRY AND TO MY AND
NICHOLS WHO IS ALSO FROM
SKYLINE HIGH SCHOOL IN OAKLAND
LET'S GIVE HIM A WARM SENATE
WELCOME. WELCOME TO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE. THANK
YOU CENTER SKINNER NOW MOVES
MOVING ON TO MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED READ
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL
BE DEEMED READ. REPORTS OF
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED. MOVING
TO MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS AND
NOTICES. THERE ARE FOUR MEMBERS
AT THE DESK THAT WILL BE DEEMED
ADOPTED. MOVING ON TO
CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY FILE
MOVING ON TO SECOND READING
FILE MISTER SECRETARY. ASSEMBLY
BILL. FOURTEEN SEVENTY FIVE FOR
TWELVE NINE TWENTY FIVE TWELVE
THIRTY FOUR EIGHTEEN TWENTY
BILL FIFTY
MAKING ME I SECRETARY SECOND
READING FILE WILL BE DEEMED
READ MOVING TO UNFINISHED
BUSINESS WE HAVE FILE ITEM
TWENTY THREE BEING PRESENTED BY
SENATOR HILL. MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL THREE
TWENTY SIX BY SENATOR HILL AN
ACT RELATING TO CIVIL LAW.
CENTER HILL THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT SB THREE TWENTY SIX
IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE THIS
MEASURE ESTABLISHES BALCONY
INSPECTION REQUIREMENTS FOR
HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATIONS AND
PREVENTS BUILDERS. FROM PLACING
LANGUAGE IN THE C. C. IN OURS
THAT WOULD LIMIT THE H. ALWAYS
ABILITY TO PURSUE CONSTRUCTION
DEFECT LITIGATION. AMENDMENTS
TAKEN IN THE ASSEMBLY REMOVED
ALL FORMAL OPPOSITION THE
CLARIFY THAT NOTHING IN THIS
MEASURE AFFECTS THE PRE
LITIGATION OBLIGATIONS CODIFIED
IN SB EIGHT HUNDRED. FROM
BURDEN OF TWO THOUSAND AND TWO
AND STRENGTH IN THE PRE
LITIGATION NOTIFICATIONS
HOMEOWNER ASSOCIATION BOARDS
ARE REQUIRED TO PROVIDE TO
THEIR MEMBERS AS MEASURE HAS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT A
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
ON CONCURRENT. THANK YOU
SENATOR HILL. SEEING NO FURTHER
DISCUSSION DEBATE MISTER
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL ALLEN.
I ARCHULETA I ATKINS AYE BATES
AYE BILL I PORGES. BRADFORD HI
CABALLERO HI CHIANG I DALY.
DODDI THEY'RE ALSO I GALGIANI
BY GLAZER BY GONZALEZ I GROWTH.
HERTZBERG AYE HILL. HIGHWAY SO
I TADO I JACKSON HI JONES NO
LEYVA. BY MCGUIRE HI MITCHELL
HI MONNING HI MORE LOCKED
MORALE. NO NIELSEN. PAN BY
PORTANTINO FIVE ROTH. HI RUBIO
I SKINNER BY STERN AYE STONE.
NO BURKE BY ALL ACCOUNTS HE- I
WIENER AYE WILK HI. CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS GORGEOUS. DALLY
GROWTH NO MORE LOCK. NIELSEN NO.
HIGHS THIRTY TWO KNOWS FIVE THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IT'S OUR
CONCURRED. MOVING TO SENATE'S
THIRD READING FILE ITEM FORTY
CENTER BASS THREE PREPARED TO
PRESENT. MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION SIXTY FOUR BY
SENATOR BATES RELATIVE TO DRUG
ABUSE. SENATOR BATES I THANK
YOU MISTER PRESIDENT MEMBERS I
RISE TO PRESENT SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION SIXTY
FOUR ARE PROCLAIMING SEPTEMBER
TWENTY NINETEEN AS OPIOID KAREN
HEROIN BENT NOW IN PRESCRIPTION
DRUG ABUSE AWARENESS MONTH OUR
NATION'S OUT. OPIOID EPIDEMIC
IS A VERY SERIOUS PUBLIC HEALTH
PROBLEM THE CENTER FOR DISEASE
CONTROL AND PREVENTION RECENTLY
REPORTED THAT NINETY ONE PEOPLE
DIE EVERY DAY IN THE UNITED
STATES FROM AN OPIOID OVERDOSE.
NOT EVERYONE WHO TAKES OPIOIDS
BECOMES ADDICTED BUT THERE IS A
VERY HIGH RISK FOR BECOMING
DRUG DEPENDENT WHEN USING
OPIOIDS THE AMOUNT OF TIME IT
MIGHT TAKE FOR WHEN TO BECOME
ADDICTED TO THE DRUG CAN VARY
FROM PERSON TO PERSON. TEENS
AND YOUNG ADULTS FIRST USE
OPIOIDS WHEN THEY ARE
PRESCRIBED TO THEM FOLLOWING AN
INJURY A ROUTINE PROCEDURE LIKE
THE REMOVAL OF WISDOM TEETH.
THIS EPIDEMIC UNDERSCORES THE
NEED FOR NON MEDICINAL OPTIONS
TO BE A PART OF THE RESOLUTION
FROM NINETEEN NINETY NINE TO
TWENTY SEVENTEEN MORE THAN FOUR
HUNDRED THOUSAND PEOPLE DIED
FROM OVERDOSES RELATED TO
PRESCRIPTION OPIOIDS IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN ALONE MORE THAN
SEVENTY THOUSAND DEATHS IN THE
UNITED STATES WERE CAUSED BY
DRUG OVERDOSE WITH OVER.
SEVENTEEN THOUSAND OF THESE
INVOLVING. PRESCRIPTION OPIOIDS.
DRUG OVERDOSES KILL MORE PEOPLE
IN A YEAR DOWN ON THE NUMBER OF
MOTOR VEHICLE FATALITIES IN THE
UNITED STATES AND IN ADDITION.
THE USE OF FAT NOW IS ON THE
RISE WITH NEARLY SEVEN TIMES
MORE CONFISCATIONS OF FAT NOW
FROM TWENTY TWELVE TO TWENTY
FOURTEEN. PLEASE JOIN ME IN
RECOGNIZING THE GRAVITY OF THE
OPIOID CRISIS AND BRING MORE
AWARENESS TO THE FACTS ARE IN
OUR COMMUNITIES I ASK FOR YOUR
AYE BUILT. THANK YOU SENATOR
BATES SENIOR FURTHER DISCUSSION
DEBATE THIS IS A CANDIDATE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SINGLE
SINGLE OBJECTIONS ICE FORTY NO
ZERO THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
MOVING ON TO ASSEMBLY THIRD
READING FILE ITEM FIFTY FIVE
SENATOR MINING ARE YOU PREPARED
TO PRESENT. PASS ON FILE. OKAY.
NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM NUMBER
SIXTY CENTER LABOR ARE YOU
PREPARED 2% MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR
SIXTY SEVEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BURNER HARPER AND THAT CLING TO
USE OF STATE PROPERTY. CENTER
LEYVA THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT
AB FOR SIXTY SEVEN WHICH WILL
REQUIRE EQUAL PRIZE PAY FOR
BOTH MEN AND WOMEN ATHLETES WE
COMPETING ON STATE PROPERTY
USED FOR RECREATION. THE SPORTS
WORLD HAS HISTORICALLY PAID
WOMEN LESS THAN MEN AND ACROSS
SPORTS SECTORS HEY DISPARITIES
STILL EXIST FOR EXAMPLE IN THE
TWO THOUSAND TEN X. GAMES THE
FIRST PLACE PRIZE FOR THE
FEMALE CATEGORY TOOK HOME TWO
THOUSAND DOLLARS WELL HER MALE
COUNTERPART TOOK HOME. FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS AND EVEN MORE
RECENTLY THE WINNING UNITED
STATES WOMEN'S SOCCER TEAM IS
JUST ANOTHER GREAT EXAMPLE AS
THEY MADE ON AVERAGE 40% LESS
THAN THEIR MALE COUNTERPARTS.
IT IS ESSENTIAL THAT OUR STATE
LANDS REFLECT OUR VALUES OF
EQUALITY AND EQUITY IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN THE
CALIFORNIA COASTAL COMMISSION
WITH THE STATE LANDS COMMISSION
DETERMINED THAT IT WOULD ONLY
LEASE THE PUBLIC BEACH. FOR THE
MAVERICKS SURF COMPETITION IF
EQUAL PRIZE COMPENSATION WAS
GUARANTEED FOR BOTH THE MEN'S
AND THE WOMEN'S DIVISION. AB
FOR SIXTY SEVEN CODIFIES THE
DECISION BY THE COASTAL
COMMISSION THE STATE LANDS
COMMISSION TO GRANT LANDLESS
PERMITS. EVENT WITH GENDER
CATEGORIES ONLY IF THE PERSON
PRIZE FOR FULL IS EQUAL FOR MEN
AND WOMEN THIS BILL WILL ALSO
PERSONALLY CODIFY THE
GROUNDWORK LAID BY CALPERS
FEMALE ATHLETES THAT ARE ALSO
STRONG AND POWERFUL ADVOCATE
FOR PAY EQUITY. MEMBERS OUR
GOAL OUR SEATS GOAL IS TO
PROMOTE EQUALITY ACROSS ALL
SECTORS OF SOCIETY I ASK YOU TO
JOIN ME TODAY IN SUPPORT OF AB
OR SIXTY SEVEN WHICH IS EARNED
RESET THANK BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
WITH HIS THRONE VOTES. IN
EITHER HOUSE I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE. IS THERE LEYVA.
SEEING NO FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ALLEN I ARCHULETA
AYE ATKINS AYE BATES BY BILL I
PURCHASED. BRADFORD BY CAMBIADO
BY CHIANG I DALY. BY DOT BY THE
RAZA I GALGIANI BY GLAZER. BY
GONZALEZ BY GROWTH I HERTZBERG.
BY HILL AYE HUESO BY TITLE I
JACKSON AYE JONES BY LEYVA. I'M
MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL BY MONEY
I'M MORE LOCK MORRELL. NIELSEN.
HI PAN AYE PORTANTINO I ROTH I
RUBIO. I SKINNER AYE STERN AYE
STONE. STONE. HI NUMBER OUR
COUNTY BY WINNER BY WILK HI.
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. YES
MORE LOCK. MORRELL. ICE THIRTY
SEVEN NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES. MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
SIXTY FOUR SENATOR HILL READY
FOR TO TWO PRESENTS A MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL SIX THIRTY BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ARAMBULA AND HACK RULING
THE HEALING ARTS. THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT. AB SIX THIRTY
WILL REQUIRE THERAPISTS TO
PROVIDE THEIR CLIENTS WITH A
PRINTED DISCLOSURE ABOUT WHERE
TO FILE A COMPLAINT ABOUT THE
THERAPIST SHOULD THE NEED
ARISE. THE DISCLOSURE WILL BE
PROVOKED WILL BE PROVIDED TO
THE CLIENT PRIOR TO SERVICES
THIS WILL ENHANCE CONSUMER
PROTECTION BY ENSURING CLIENTS
ARE AWARE OF THE CORRECT
COMPLAINT PROCESS SHOULD ANY
ISSUES OCCUR DURING THE COURSE
OF THEIR THERAPY. IT ALSO MAKES
A MINOR IN CLARIFYING AMENDMENT
TO CURRENT LAW REGARDING
CLINICAL SOCIAL WORK STUDENTS
AND TO LEADS AN OBSOLETE
REFERENCES MAJOR HAS ENJOYED
UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR RIVAL
MEMBERS. THANK YOU SENATOR
SEEING NO FURTHER DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN. I
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE BATES
BY BILL I BRIDGES I BRADFORD I
CAMBIADO I CHIANG I DALY I DODD
HI DORADO I GALGIANI I GLAZER I
GONZALEZ BY GROVE. HERTZBERG I
HILL AYE HUESO I HER TITLE I
JACKSON I JONES I LIVE A- HI
MCGUIRE BY MITCHELL. BY MONNING
I'M MORE LUCK I'M A REAL. AYE
NIELSEN AYE PAN AYE PORTANTINO.
HI. ROTH HI RUBIO BY SKINNER I
STERN AYE STONE. I AM BURKE I
HAVE A COUNTY BY WINNER. WILK
HI WORK I. MISTER SECRETARY
CALLED ABSENT MEMBERS GROWTH.
WIENER WIENER. PRICE THIRTY
NINE TWO ZERO MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM SIXTY
SEVEN AS CENTER LEYVA LOOKS
LIKE SHE'S PREPARED TO PRESENT
SO MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT OH NINE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SANTIAGO AND
ACCORDING TO PUBLIC POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION. CENTER
LABOR THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT GOOD AFTERNOON AGAIN
MEMBERS AB EIGHT OH NINE WILL
REQUIRE PUBLIC COLLEGES TO POST
TITLE NINE PROTECTIONS FOR
PREGNANT AND PARENTING STUDENTS
ON THEIR WEBSITE AND ENCOURAGE
ON CAMPUS CHILD CARE CENTRES.
TOO BRIGHT PRIORITIZE ENROLLING
CHILDREN OF LOW INCOME SINGLE
PARENTS TITLE NINE OFFERS
PREGNANT STUDENTS PROTECTIONS
SUCH AS THE ABILITY TO MAKE UP
MISSED WORK AND ACCOMMODATIONS
LIKE LARGER DESKS. MANY ARE NOT
AWARE OF THESE PROTECTIONS AND
AS A RESULT MAY DROP OUT OF
COLLEGE POSTINGS INFORMATIONAL
MAKE STUDENTS AWARE OF THEIR
RIGHTS AND AVAILABLE RESOURCES
TO HELP THEM GRADUATE. IN
ADDITION ENCOURAGING THE
ENROLLMENT OF CHILDREN OF LOW
INCOME SINGLE PARENTS CAN HELP
THESE STUDENTS SECURE
AFFORDABLE AND FLEXIBLE CHILD
CARE I THINK THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FOR THIS IMPORTANT BILL.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER LEYVA
EE NO FURTHER DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION MISTER SECRETARY
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN HI.
ARCHULETA I HAD CONCERT BY
BATES BELL I FOR JUST BY
BRADFORD I CAMBIADO I CHIANG I
DALY I DODD HI THERE ALSO I
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER BY GONZALEZ.
BY GROVE. HERTZBERG AYE HILL
AYE HUESO. HI TACO I JACKSON I
JONES BY LEYVA. MCGUIRE HI
MITCHELL BY MONNING HI MORE
LOCKED MORALE. NIELSEN. I PAN
AYE PORTANTINO I ROTH I RUBIO I
SKINNER I STERN AYE STONE. BY
BURKE HI BY WHAT COUNTY I
WIENER AYE WILK HI. MISTER
SECRETARY CALLED ABSENT MEMBERS
BATES BY GROWTH BY LEYVA I MORE
LUCK BY MORRELL. HIGHS THIRTY
NINE NO ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM SEVENTY
CENTER HERTZBERG ARE YOU
PREPARED. MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL
FOURTEEN FOURTEEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN AN ACT
RELATING TO WATER. THANK YOU A-
FLEA MISTER UP PRESIDENT AS A
RESULT OF NEARLY TWO YEARS OF
NEGOTIATION OF THIS LEGISLATURE
BOTH HOUSES TOGETHER WITH
GOVERNOR BROWN PASSED A LONG
TERM WATER USE EFFICIENCY
LEGISLATIVE PACKAGE IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN. TO MAKE
CONSERVATION A WAY OF LIFE
THOSE ARE SB SIX OH SIX AND A.
B. SIXTEEN SIXTY EIGHT WHICH
CREATED THIS COMPREHENSIVE
FRAMEWORK FOR WATER
CONSERVATION. THERE WERE ISSUES
RAISED IMPLEMENTATION OF THESE
LANDMARK BILLS THIS BILL ARE A
B. FOURTEEN FOURTEEN B. ALIGNS
THE VARIOUS REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS ESTABLISHED BY
LAST YEAR'S LEGISLATION FOR THE
ALL REQUIRED WATER USE REPORTS
OF A CREATURE OF TIME LINE I
ASK YOU AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
CENTER HERTZBERG. SEEING NO
FURTHER DEBATE OR DISCUSSION
THIS IS A CANDIDATE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SEEING
NINE EYES FORTY KNOWS ZERO
MEASURE PASSES MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM SEVENTY FOUR PASS ON
FILE NOW MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
EIGHTY FIVE SENATOR PANTY
PREPARED MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL SIX
EIGHTY NINE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MCCARTY AND EXPLAIN TO THE
MUNICIPAL UTILITY DISTRICT ACT.
MR CENTER PAN THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT CENTERS I RISE TODAY
THE PERCENT EIGHTY SIX NINETY
EIGHT BY A SUMMER CARTY WHICH
IS A DISTRICT BILL WHICH WILL
ALLOW THE SECOND WOMAN THIS
BILL UTILITY DISTRICT ARE SMART
TO RECEIVE NON STOCK EQUITY IN
THE COMPANY EXCHANGE FOR
PROVIDING ASSISTANCE AND
EXPERTISE. INVESTOR OWNED
UTILITIES BECAUSE OF THE
CORPORATE STRUCTURE ARE ALREADY
ABLE TO HOLD EQUITY AND OTHER
COMPANIES. SMUGNESS MANY IS YOU
KNOW WAS HERE IS THE
ELECTRICITY PROVIDER FOR THE
SACRAMENTO REGION AS A PUBLIC
AGENCY WOULD CONSISTENTLY
PROVIDES POWER AT MUCH LOWER
RATES THAN INVESTOR OWNED
UTILITIES. IT'S ALSO BEEN AT
THE FOREFRONT THE CARBON ISING
ARE GREAT. RIGHT NOW SMUD WORKS
WITH BUSINESSES BY OFFERING
THEIR EXPERTISE IN ELECTRICITY
AND POWER MANAGEMENT THIS IS
ESPECIALLY HELPFUL FOR EMERGING
GREEN TECHNOLOGIES WHICH ARE
USUALLY UNDER START UP PHASE
WHEN THEY WORK WITH SMUD. OF
THOSE BUSINESSES ARE PURCHASED
BY ANOTHER COMPANY SMUD WOULD
BE ABLE TO REVISE RETURN ON THE
VALUE OF THAT EQUITY. CURRENTLY
**** DOES NOT HAVE THE ABILITY
TO REALIZE THAT RETURN. THIS
BILL IS DUE BENEFITS AND
ENCOURAGING THE DEVELOPMENT OF
GREEN TECHNOLOGIES TO HELP
CALIFORNIA REACH OUR AMBITIOUS
CLIMATE GOALS AN OFFSETTING
SOME OF THE RATE INCREASE IS
NECESSARY TO REACH THOSE GOALS.
IT'S ALSO A FAIRNESS ISSUE THE
RATE PAYERS US MUCH SHOULD HAVE
THE SAME OPPORTUNITY THE RETURN
ON THEIR INTELLECTUAL PROPERTY
AT THE SHAREHOLDERS OF PGA ANY
AND OTHERS. THIS BILL IS
RECEIVED. BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
EXPECTEDLY ASKED FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER PAN.
SEEING NO FURTHER TO SPADER
DISCUSSION THIS IS A CANNED IF
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. OR IS ROLL
CALL I THOUGHT WOULD MAKE UP
FOR THE ONE I MISTER EARLIER
OKAY WE'RE GONNA GO ROLL CALL
THE. MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ALLEN. HI
ARCHULETA I ATKINS I BATES.
BELL I PURCHASED. HI BRADFORD I
CAMBIADO I CHIANG BY DAILY DOT
HI THERE ALSO I GALGIANI BY
GLAZER BY GONZALEZ I GROW.
HERTZBERG. I HILL AYE HUESO HI
TITLE HI JACKSON I JONES NO.
LEYVA. I AM AYE MITCHELL AYE
MONNING I'M MORE LOCK MERRELL.
NIELSEN PAN I PORTANTINO I ROTH
BY RUBIO I SKINNER I STERN AYE
STONE. NUMBER I LIKE COUNTY I
WINNER HI WILK HI. MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS BATES. DALY
GROVE. MORE LOCK MORRELL.
NIELSEN STONE. SIZE THIRTY TWO
KNOWS ONE THE MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM ONE
HUNDRED. SENATOR HERTZBERG NO
I'M SORRY CENTER GLAZER. MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL SEVEN FOURTEEN BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WOULD AND THAT GOING TO
HEALING ARTS AND CLING THERE'S
THERE UP TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY CENTER GLAZER THANK
YOU MISTER PRESIDENT MEMBERS AM
PLEASED TO PRESENT AB SEVEN
FOURTEEN BY ASSEMBLY NUMBER
WOULD. THIS IS REFERRED TO IN
OUR PARLANCE IS A CLEANUP BILL
TO CLEAN UP TO AB TWENTY SEVEN
SIXTY OF LAST YEAR THAT
REQUIRED PRESCRIBERS. TO OFFER
A CO PRESCRIPTION. OF NEW LOCKS
AND OR ANOTHER FDA APPROVED
OPIOID OVERDOSE REVERSAL DRUG
WHENEVER THEY OFFER AN OPIOID.
LARA BENZO DIAZ BEAN
PRESCRIPTION TO SPECIFIC
CATEGORIES OF AT RISK PATIENTS
AB SEVEN FOURTEEN PROVIDES AN
EXEMPTION FOR PRESCRIBERS WHEN
TREATING TERMINALLY ILL
PATIENTS ALSO AN EXEMPTION FOR
VETERINARIANS THE THESE ARE THE
ELEMENTS OF THE BILL CLARIFIES
SPECIFIES THE REQUIREMENTS AND
WITH THAT THAT'S GOT BY
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT WITHOUT
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SIR. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION WE'RE DEBATE.
THIS IS A CARE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL. SEEING NONE. THE
URGENCY PASSES FORTY TO ZERO IN
ON THE MEASURE SELF ICE FORTY
KNOWS ZERO MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM ONE TWENTY PASS ON FILE.
WE'LL PROCEED NOW TO FILE ITEM
ONE THIRTY ONE SENATOR ALLEN
ARE YOU PREPARED. SEEING THAT
YOU ARE MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
READ ASSEMBLY BILL SIX FIFTY
THREE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM
AN ACCOLADE ARMORIES. THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT HI SB SIX
FIFTY THREE AUTHORIZES THE
DIRECTOR GENERAL SERVICES TO
ENTER INTO A LEASE AGREEMENT
WITH THE COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES
FOR PORTION OF THE WEST LOS
ANGELES NATIONAL GUARD ARMORY
SITE THAT IS IN MY DISTRICT.
AND THAT OF AS A MEMBER BLOOM
OVER THE LAST YEAR AND A HALF
LA COUNTY SUPERVISORS YOU LOOK
YOU'LL HAS WORKED WITH THE CITY
STATE AND FEDERAL STAKEHOLDERS
TO DISCUSS THE FEASIBILITY OF
CLOSING THE CURRENT WINTER
SHELTER PROGRAM AT THE WEST
VALLEY ARMORY AND INSTEAD
BUILDING A YEAR ROUND BRIDGE
HOUSING ON A PORTION OF THE
PARKING LOT WHICH IS NOT USED
FOR MILITARY PURPOSES. BRIDGE
HOUSING FOLKS MAY KNOW IS A
TWENTY FOUR HOUR DORMITORY
STYLE LIVING QUARTERS WHICH
GIVES CALIFORNIA'S EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS GREATER ACCESS TO
WRAP AROUND SERVICES IN A SAFE
ENVIRONMENT HI THIS WEST LA
ARMORY SITS IN THE MIDDLE OF A
REGION WHICH FREQUENTLY CAM AND
SOME OF THE HIGHEST PROPERTY
VALUES ALL CALIFORNIA THIS
INNOVATIVE COST EFFECTIVE
COLLABORATION ADDRESS
HOMELESSNESS WITH WHICH IS
LEGISLATION FACILITIES AS A
STRONG SUPPORTER THE STATE'S.
SURROUNDING COMMUNITIES IS
ENJOYED STRONG BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT HAS NO. OPPOSITION AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE
ON THIS IMPORTANT ON OUR REGION.
THANK YOU CENTER ALLEN. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
THIS MEASURES I CAN'T AS A
CANDIDATE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. SEEM NO OBJECTIONS THAT
THE MEASURE PASSES FORTY TWO
ZERO. NOW WE'RE TO GO BACK TO
FILE ITEM ONE TWENTY I NEED TO
APOLOGIZE TO CENTER Y. CASKEY I
CAN'T READ MY OWN WRITING I
THOUGHT IT WAS WILK IT WAS MY
CASKEY AND SO WITH THAT YOU ARE
READY SO MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN
A SEVEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KALRA AN ACTING TO PUBLIC
CONTRACTS. POLICIES ACCEPTED
MISTER PRESIDENT AB SEVEN A
SEVEN SEAT DISTRICT BILL WITH
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IT UPDATES
THE FORMAL BIDDING PROCESS FOR
CONTRACTING BY THE SANTA CLARA
VALLEY WATER DISTRICT IT
CONTRACTING FOR MINOR PROJECTS
IN A TIMELY MANNER ENHANCES THE
AGENCY'S ABILITY TO MAINTAIN
WATER SUPPLY AND FLOOD CONTROL
INFRASTRUCTURE AS WELL AS MEET
AS WELL AS MEETING ITS
ENVIRONMENTAL STEWARDSHIP
RESPONSIBILITY. IT'LL HELP
DELIVER SMALL PROJECTS AT LOWER
COST I REGION I VOTE. THANK YOU
SENATOR. SEE NO FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE THIS IS A
CANDIDATE FOR AN ANIMUS ROLL
CALL. THANK YOU MISTER
SECRETARY FOR REVERSING YOUR
DECISION ALL RIGHT WITHOUT
OBVIOUS SECRETARY CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN. HI ARCHULETA I
ATKINS I BATES. HI BILL I
PURCHASED BY BRADFORD I
CABALLERO I CHIANG. I DALY I
DODD HI THERE ALSO. I GALGIANI
AYE GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ BY
GROVE. HI HERTZBERG BY HILL I
WAS SO. BY HER TITLE I JACKSON.
HI JONES BY LEYVA BY MCGUIRE I
MITCHELL BY MORNING. BY MORE
LOCK I'M A REAL. BY NELSON. BY
PAN AYE PORTANTINO I ROTH I
RUBIO I SKINNER I STERN BY
STONE. HI NUMBER OUR COUNTY. I
WINNER BY WILK HI. BUYS FORTY
NO ZERO MEASURE PASSES. MOVING
ON TO FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY TWO
SENATOR BALLOTS LIKE HE'S
PREPARED TO PRESENT SO MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. THE BILL
SEVENTY FIVE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BLOOM AND ACTUALLY TO TISSUE
BANKS. SENATOR BELL THANK YOU A
MISS PRESENT MEMBERS THIS IS A
TECHNICAL CLEAN UP TO BETTER
STREAMLINE THE TRANSFER
POURTANT DONOR MEDICAL HISTORY
INFORMATION FROM ONE BANK TO
ANOTHER THE BILL ALIGNS THE
EXISTING STATE COSTA HARMONIZE
WITH THE FOR DRUG
ADMINISTRATION REGULATIONS FOR
DONOR IDENTITY REQUIREMENTS
INTO SHE TRANSFERS AND IT ALSO
HELPS REGULATE KAMI BANKS TO
PROVIDE ALL FAMILIES AND
CHILDREN CONCEIVED FROM DONOR
TISSUES WITH NECESSARY
INFORMATION TO MAKE INFORMED
HEALTH DECISIONS IN THE FUTURE
HOUSING I'M SUPPORT. REGION I
VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER BELL ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
SEEING NONE THIS IS A CANDIDATE
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SEEING
NO OBJECTIONS ICE FORTY NO ZERO
MEASURE PASSES MOVING ON TO
CENTER Y. CASKEY LOOKS LIKE
HE'S PREPARED 2% WITH THAT
MISTER SECRETARY IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE READ A SOME OF THE
ELEVEN TWENTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES AND ACT
REALLY INTO TOXICS THEIR Y.
CASKEY MISTER PRESENT THIS BILL
SIMPLY INSURES THAT THE
ATTORNEY JOURNAL GENERAL THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA RECEIVES
PROPER NOTICE AND A COPY OF A
PROP SIXTY FIVE APPEALS
CURRENTLY THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE ENGAGES IN.
PROP SIXTY FIVE LITIGATION THE
CURRENT LAW DOES NOT REQUIRE
NOTICE OF APPEALS AB ELEVEN
TWENTY THREE IS TECHNICAL BILL
NOW OFFERS PARTNER JUST AS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PARTICIPATE IN
ANY LITIGATION THAT COULD.
ESTABLISH STATEWIDE PRESIDENT'S
INSURERS. THAT THAT THE
PROCEEDINGS OCCUR ARE
CONSISTENT AND EFFICIENT AS
POSSIBLE AND I REGION I VOTE.
THANK YOU SIR Y. CASKEY. SEE NO
FURTHER DEBATER DISCUSSION
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL THIS DOES REQUIRE TWO
THIRDS VOTE. ALLEN I ARCHULETA
I ATKINS BY BATES. NO BELL I
PURCHASED. NO BRADFORD I
CAMBIADO I CHIANG. NO DALY NO
DOT. HI THERE ALSO I GALGIANI I
GLAZER HI GONZALEZ I GROWTH NO
HERTZBERG I HILL AYE HUESO. HI
TITLE HI JACKSON I JONES. NOTE
LEYVA. BY MCGUIRE MITCHELL. HI
MONNING I'M MORE LUCK NO MORALE.
NO NIELSEN NO PAN BY PORTANTINO
I ROTH I RUBIO I SKINNER I
STERN AYE STONE NO NUMBER. I
WOULD COUNTY I WIENER BY WILK
NO. AYE AYES TWENTY NINE KNOWS
ELEVEN THE MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM ONE
NINETY NINE. CENTER GALGIANI
ARE YOU PREPARED MR SECRETARY
PLEASE READ READ THE- THIS CALL
THE ROLL. ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT
SEVENTY TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY IN EQUITY TAXATION
TO TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY TAX
LEVY. GALGIANI THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS AB EIGHT SEVENTY
TWO WILL HELP CHILDREN ON SMALL
FAMILY FARMS STAY IN THEIR HOME
AFTER THE DEATH OF A PARENT
PARENT CHILD EXCLUSIONS
GENERALLY PREVENT PROPERTY TAX
REASSESSMENT WHEN PROPERTY
CHANGES HANDS WITHIN THE FAMILY
FROM PARENT TO CHILD. THE
LEGISLATURE HAS CONSISTENTLY
SUPPORTED THESE EXCLUSIONS
BECAUSE THEY HELP CHILDREN
STAND THEIR FAMILY HOME AFTER
THE LOSS OF A PARENT DO A SMALL
GAP IN OUR COMPLICATED TAX LAWS
NOT ALL SMALL FAMILY FARM
HOMESTEADS GET A PARENT CHILD
EXCLUSION. AB EIGHT SEVENTY TWO
CORRECT THIS INEQUITY IN THE
LAW ON A GOING FORWARD BASIS
WHICH WILL PROTECT SMALL FAMILY
FARMERS THE BILL IS SUPPORTED
BY STATE TREASURER FIONA MA AND
THE BOARD OF EQUALIZATION. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR SEEING
NO FURTHER DEBATE OR DISCUSSION
THIS IS A CANDIDATE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SEEING NO
OBJECTIONS HIGHS FORTY NO ZERO
MEASURE PASSES. MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM TO CENTER JONES IT
LOOKS LIKE HE'S PREPARED SO
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL TEN SIXTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN AN APPLE
INTO INSURANCE. CENTERJONES
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
MEMBERS A. B. TEN SIXTY FIVE
WOULD MAKE PERMANENT THE
ABILITY OF INSURERS TO OFFER
CONSUMERS THE OPTION OF
RECEIVING CERTAIN DOCUMENTS
ELECTRONICALLY. THE ADVANTAGES
TO OPTIONAL TRYING TRANSACTIONS
ARE NUMEROUS INCLUDING
ADDITIONAL CONSUMER CHOICE
FASTER DELIVERY REDUCE COSTS
AND PORTABILITY AND IN THE
AFTERMATH OF A DISASTER THE
ABILITY FOR CONSUMERS WHO HAVE
SUFFERED LOSSES. AND INSURERS
TO CONDUCT TRANSACTIONS
ELECTRONICALLY CAN ACCELERATE
THE RECOVERY PROCESS EXISTING
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS ARE NOT
ONLY RETAINED BUT ENHANCE UNDER
THE BILL I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE THIS AFTERNOON.
THANK YOU SIR. THREE NO FURTHER
TO A DISCUSSION OR DEBATE THIS
IS A CANNED IF UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. SEEING NO OBJECTIONS AYE
AYES FORTY NO ZERO MEASURE
PASSES. MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
TWO OH FOUR WITH CENTER RUBIO
IS TO PRESENT MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL TEN
NINETY NINE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CALDERON AND ACT REALLY INTO
INSURANCE CENTER RUBIO. THANK
YOU MISTER PRESIDENT TODAY I
RISE TO PRESENT AB TEN NINETY
NINE SINCE NINETEEN NINETY SIX
THE CALIFORNIA ORGANIZED
INVESTMENT NETWORK WORK POINT
PROGRAM HAS FACILITATED
INSURANCE INDUSTRY INVESTMENTS
THAT BENEFIT CALIFORNIA'S
ENVIRONMENT AND IT'S LOW TO
MODERATE INCOME AND RURAL
COMMUNITIES THE BILL REQUIRES
LARGE INSURANCE COMPANIES TO
REPORT TO THE INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER THEIR COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT INVESTMENT HOLDINGS
IN CALIFORNIA FROM TWENTY
SIXTEEN TO TWENTY TWENTY. AS
WELL AS OTHER THE SITE SO STYLE
BE BENEFICIAL TYPES OF
INVESTMENTS SUCH AS INVESTMENTS
MADE IN ENVIRONMENTALLY
FRIENDLY PROJECTS THIS
INFORMATION PROVIDES INSIGHT
INTO INSURERS INVESTMENT
PRACTICES THE BILL ALSO EXTENDS
THE SUNSET ON POINT ADVISORY
BOARD TO JANUARY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY NINE THE ADVISORY BOARD
PROVIDES GUIDANCE TO THE
PROGRAM AND HELPS CONNECT THE
PROGRAM TO INDUSTRY LEADERS. AB
TEN NINETY NINE HAS NO KNOWN
OPPOSITION AND IT'S SUPPORTED
BY INSURANCE COMMISSIONER
RICARDO LARA NUMEROUS COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT ORGANIZATIONS AND A
LARGE INSURANCE TRADE
ASSOCIATION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I POD THANK YOU THANK
YOU SENATOR ANY FURTHER DEBATE
OR DISCUSSION SEEING NONE. THIS
IS A CANDIDATE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL. SEEING NO OBJECTIONS
OUR EYES FORTY NO ZERO MEASURE
PASSES MOVING ON NOW TO FILE
ITEM TWO TWO FIVE SENATOR
PORTANTINO ARE YOU PREPARED.
WITH THAT MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL NINE
EIGHTY FOUR BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LACKEY AND ACCOLADES TAXATION
IN MAKING AN APPROPRIATION
THERE FOR CENTER PORTANTINO
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
MEMBERS TODAY I AM PROUD TO
PRESENT AB NINE EIGHTY FOUR ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER FROM
MY COLLEAGUE FROM PALMDALE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LACKEY. AB NINE
EIGHTY FOUR WILL CREATE A
VOLUNTARY CONTRIBUTION FUND TO
PROVIDE MORE RESOURCES FOR
SUICIDE PREVENTION THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN YEAR NEARLY FORTY
THREE HUNDRED INDIVIDUALS TOOK
THEIR OWN LIVES MANY OF THESE
ARE YOUNG PEOPLE A SUICIDE IS
THE SECOND AND THIRD LEADING
CAUSE OF DEATH. AMONG CHILDREN
AND YOUNG ADULTS THIS IS AN
ALARMING INCREASE SINCE TWO
THOUSAND ONE WHEN RATES WERE
50% LOWER THAN THEY ARE TODAY
MORE SUICIDE PREVENTION AND
CRISIS INTERVENTION SERVICES
ARE NEEDED FOR AT RISK
POPULATIONS PARTICULARLY THOSE
IN RURAL LOCATIONS. AND SUICIDE
IS MOST PREVALENT IN RURAL
PARTS OF OUR STATE AB NINETY
FOUR CRATES A VOLUNTARY
CONTRIBUTION CHECKOFF FUND TO
ADDRESS THE URGENT NEED OF THE
STATE AND GIVES HIGHER PRIORITY
TO NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS
LOCATED IN RURAL AREAS THE BILL
HAS STRONG BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR
THERE ARE MORE LOCK. THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES
AYE OPPOSED AB NINE EIGHTY FOUR
AND COMMITTEE THE GOVERNANCE
AND FINANCE COMMITTEE FOR ONE
REASON. THE VOLUNTARY
CONTRIBUTION OPPORTUNITIES ON
THE CALIFORNIA INCOME TAX
RETURN FOR INDIVIDUALS THE FORM
FIVE FORTY. ARE BEING IGNORED.
LESS THAN 2% OF OUR POPULATION
IS EVEN CHECKING OFF ONE OF THE
BOXES AND TAX PRACTITIONERS ARE
NOT EVEN INFORMING THEIR
CLIENTS THAT THERE'S AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CONTRIBUTE VIA
THIS. OPPORTUNITY. SO WE GOT A
LOT OF WONDERFUL CAUSES A READY
ON THE TAXI DURING THAT ARE
JUST NOT. BEING. UTILIZED
CONSEQUENT FLEA CONSEQUENTLY WE
WORK ON LEGISLATION THIS YEAR
TO IMPROVE THIS FIVE PAGE FORM
BY TRYING TO. DO A LITTLE
RESEARCH AND TRY TO SEE HOW DO
WE GET THE NONPROFIT SECTOR
INVOLVED UNFORTUNATELY SENATE
BILL TWO FORTY ONE WENT TO
PURGATORY AND SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS. COLLEAGUES WE
DO NOT KNOW NEW VOLUNTARY
CONTRIBUTION A FAVOR BY ADDING
TO A LENGTHY AND IGNORED LIST
OF TWENTY SEVEN OTHER
ALTERNATIVES THAT IN LIKE THE
SELECTED FEW ARE FORTUNATE TO
HAVE A LEGISLATOR TO PUT THEM
ON THE FORM BUT WE NEED TO GET
THE NONPROFIT COMMUNITY.
INVOLVED IN TURBO CHARGE. THIS
IMPORTANT METHOD OF CHARITABLE
GIFT GIVING OTHERWISE EVERY
CURRENT OPTION WILL LANGUISH
AND MISS THE REQUIRED
THRESHOLD. THAT ARE REQUIRED
EVERY YEAR TO BE RAISED. SO IF
YOU'RE NOT ON THE FORM YOU'RE
NOT GOING TO. PUSH FOR AND ONLY
THE SELECTED. CHARITIES ON THE
FORMER OR TRYING TO MAKE
NOTICES BUT IT'S JUST NOT
WORKING SO MISTER CHAIR I WILL
BE A NO VOTE NOT BECAUSE I'M
OPPOSED TO THE BECAUSE THEY'RE
ALL GREAT I THINK WE NEED TO
STEP BACK AND SEE WHAT WE CAN
AND DO TO IMPROVE THIS PORTION
OF THE FORM FIVE FORTY. THANK
YOU MISTER PRESIDENT THANK YOU
SIR MORE LOCK. SEEING NO
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CENTER PORTANTINO YOU MAY CLOSE
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU WITH THAT
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ALLEN. HI. ARCHULETA I
ATKINS AYE BATES BY BILL I
PORGES HI BRADFORD. HI CAFIERO
BY CHIANG I DALY BY DODD HI
THERE ARE SO I GALGIANI I
GLAZER BY GONZALEZ I GROWTH I
HERTZBERG I HILL AYE HUESO. I
TADO I JACKSON BY JONES. HI
LEYVA BY MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL
HI MONNING. BY MORE LUCK NO
MORRELL. HI NIELSEN. PAN AYE
PORTANTINO HI ROSS. BY RUBIO BY
SKINNER. STERN BY STONE BY
HAMBURG. HI MY COUNTY BY WINNER
HI WILK BY. MISTER SECRETARY
CALLED ABSENT MEMBERS NIELSEN
HI SKINNER HI. HIGHS THIRTY
NINE KNOWS ONE MEASURE PASSES
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM TO
THIRTY SENATOR UMBERG. MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL TWELVE NINETY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SALAS AN ACT
RELATING TO CRIMINAL
PROFITEERING CENTER I'M BURKE
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
MEMBERS PLEASE PRESENT AB
TWELVE NINETY FOUR AB TWELVE
NINETY FOUR WILL ENABLE LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO MORE EFFECTIVELY
IMPACT. THE INDUSTRY OF ILLEGAL
GAMBLING SWEEPSTAKES CAFES AND
ILLEGAL GAMBLING ENTERPRISES
USING ARCADE STYLE MACHINES OR
AN EPIDEMIC IN CALIFORNIA
PARTICULARLY IN ORANGE COUNTY
AND IN PARTICULAR MY DISTRICT
THESE ILLEGAL OPERATIONS OFTEN
ACT AS A MAGNET FOR MORE
SERIOUS CRIMES SUCH AS DRUGS
ROBBERIES AND OTHER CRIMES OF
VIOLENCE CURRENTLY LAW
ENFORCEMENT DOES NOT POSSESS
THE TOOLS SO EFFECTIVELY SHUT
DOWN THESE GAMBLING OPERATIONS.
AND I US RELIABLE. THANK YOU
SIR SEE NO FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE THIS IS A CANDIDATE
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SEEING
NO OBJECTIONS AYE AYES FORTY NO
ZERO MEASURE PASSES. NOW MOVE
ON TO FILE ITEM TO THIRTY ONE
SENATOR BRADFORD. MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ A SYMBOL
FOR THIRTEEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
JONES SAWYER AN APPLE IN THE
YOUTH. CENTER BRADFORD THANK
YOU IS PRESENT AT AB FOR
THIRTEEN SIMPLY CHANGES THE
TERM AT RISK TO ACT PROMISE IN
EDUCATION IN PENAL CODES
ADDRESSES A STIGMATIZED. LABEL
USED TO DESCRIBE STUDENTS
LIVING IN DIFFICULT SITUATIONS
AND FOCUSES ON THEIR LIKELIHOOD
OF BECOMING ANOTHER STATISTIC.
THIS EXPECTATION TO FAILS
STIFLES OUR STUDENTS
OPPORTUNITY AND IS A MENTALLY
THE MENTALITY I SHOULD SAY
THAT'S ALL TO PER A PERVASIVE
IN OUR SCREWS COMMUNITIES AND
JUSTICE SYSTEM PERCEPTION
MATTERS AND OUR YOUTH ARE
GREATER THAN THERE ARE
SITUATIONS. LET'S BE
INTENTIONAL WHERE OUR WORDS AND
EMPOWER OUR STUDENTS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU SIR. SEEING NO
FURTHER DEBATE OR DISCUSSION
THIS REQUIRES A ROLL CALL SO
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL OUR. I ARCHULETA AYE
ATKINS AYE BATES. BILL. I
PORCHES I BRADFORD. I CARILLO I
CHIANG I DALY. DOT HI THERE
ALSO. HI GALGIANI. BY GLAZER
AYE GONZALEZ BY GROVE.
HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO
AYE HURTADO BY JACKSON. JONES I
LEYVA I MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL.
HI MONNING 'M MORE LARK MORALE.
NIELSEN. I PAN BY PORTANTINO BY
ROTH AYE RUBIO I SKINNER AYE
STERN AYE STONE. NO NUMBER HI
MY COUNTY I WINNER BY WILK HI.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS BATES. DALY
NO GROW BY JACKSON MORE LOCK
MORRELL. ICE THIRTY FOUR KNOWS
TO MEASURE PASSES. NOW MOVE ON
TO FILE ITEM TWO THIRTY TWO AND
THE EVER POPULAR SENATOR FROM
ORANGE COUNTY'S CENTER I'M
BURKE YOU READY TO PRESENT
MISTER SECRETARY BRODY'S READ
ASSEMBLY BILL NINE FIFTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER DEEP AND ACT
REALLY INTO TELECOMMUNICATIONS
CENTER UMBERG WELL THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT THAT ACCOLADE
MISTER PRESIDENT MEMBERS TODAY
I'M PRESENT AB NINE FIFTY SIX
WILL HELP ENSURE OUR LOCAL
COMMITTEES ARE PREPARE THE
EVENT. OF AN EMERGENCY WHAT
THIS DOES IS IT ALLOWS PUBLIC
SAFETY AGENCIES TO CONDUCT
EMERGENCY TESTS ON LANDLINE
PHONES USING ALL MODES OF
EMERGENCY. COMMUNICATION. I
ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU SIR SEE NO FURTHER DEBATER
DISCUSSION THIS IS A CANDIDATE
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SEEING
NO OBJECTIONS AYE AYES FORTY
KNOWS ZERO MEASURE PASSES
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM TWO
THIRTY THREE SENATOR GONZALEZ
LOOKS LIKE SHE IS PREPARED SO
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL TEN SEVENTEEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BURNER **** BATH
AND ACTUALLY TO RAILROADS.
CENTER GONZALEZ THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT AND COLLEAGUES
I AM PROUD TO STAND AS A CO
AUTHOR OF AB TEN SEVENTEEN
WHICH SEEKS TO IMPROVE THE
SAFETY OF PEDESTRIANS AROUND
RAILROAD CROSSINGS ARE BROUGHT
TO YOU BY MY COLLEAGUE ON THE
OTHER SIDE. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BOERNER HORVATH ACCORDING TO
THE MOST RECENT FINDINGS BY THE
FEDERAL RAILROAD ADMINISTRATION
SIX OF THE TEN MOST DANGEROUS
COUNTIES FOR FATAL ACCIDENTS
BETWEEN TRAINS AND PEDESTRIANS
ARE IN CALIFORNIA. JUST IN THE
SIX CALIFORNIAS CITIES THERE
WERE OF THREE HUNDRED FORTY
SEVEN PEDESTRIAN CASUALTIES
BETWEEN TWENTY THIRTEEN AND
TWENTY SEVENTEEN ONE HUNDRED
TEN OF THESE CASUALTIES WERE IN
THE COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES. THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
REVIEWING AND APPROVING
APPLICATIONS FOR NEW RAILROAD
CROSSINGS HOWEVER ABC TEN
SEVENTEEN REQUIRES THAT THE
CPUC. INSURERS AN ENGINEER IS
AVAILABLE TO REVIEW A CITIES OR
COUNTIES SAFETY PLANS PRIOR TO
SUBMITTING FOR APPROVAL FROM
THE CPUC BY REQUIRING THIS IF
YOU SEE TO MAKE A SEAT
ASSESSMENT OF A RAILROAD
CROSSING AVAILABLE TO LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS DURING THE
PLANNING PROCESS. CITIES CAN
DECREASE THE LIKELIHOOD OF
ACCIDENTAL FATALITIES AROUND
THESE CROSSINGS PLEASE JOIN ME
IN ENSURING THAT FUTURE
RAILROAD CROSSINGS ARE SAFE FOR
PEDESTRIANS AND THAT WE DON'T
LOSE ANOTHER THREE HUNDRED
FORTY SEVEN PEOPLE TO DANGEROUS
CROSSINGS THIS BILL HAS SUPPORT
ON BOTH SIDES WITH NO KNOWN
OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH SENATOR ALLEN. I OF COURSE
FOR THE OTHER. ARE YOU WILLING
TO TAKE A QUESTION. YEAH YES.
THAT YOU CAN SAY YES YOU SAY NO
OR YOU MAY CHOOSE TO ANSWER IN
YOUR CLOTHES. I'VE ANSWERED MY
CLOTHES HAVE WITH THAT. YOU
WOULD YOU GOT THE SENATOR I
SHOULD KNOW THAT IS OUT VERY
USUAL. BUT AT THAT TIME I WAS
HOPING THAT THAT EITHER INNER
CLOSE OR DURING THE DEBATE HI
CENTER MENTIONED THAT OTHER SIX
COUNTY SHE MENTIONED SIX
COUNTIES AT LIVE REALLY LOVE TO
KNOW WHAT THE SIX COUNTIES ARE
AND. HIGH HOPES A BILL TO
PROVIDE THAT INFORMATION THE
CLOSE. WE'LL GET THAT IN THE
END  DON'T KNOW THEM OFFHAND
THEIR SIX CITIES ACTUALLY BUT
THEY MAY BE CITY COUNCIL FIND
OUT FOR YOU. THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION NOW. SENATOR WIENER.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT A
QUESTION FOR THE AUTHOR. THERE
GONZALEZ YOU REALLY TAKE A
QUESTION SURE THROUGH THE CHAIR
THE CHAIR. THROUGH THE CHAIR GO
AHEAD. THROUGH THE CHAIR IT
THIS REQUIRES THE CPC TO
PROVIDE AN ENGINEER TO HELP
LOCAL GOVERNMENT BUT WE KNOW
WE'RE IN AN ECONOMIC BOOM AND
WE HAVE A SHORTAGE OF ENGINEERS
TO THE QUESTION IS WHAT HAPPENS
IF. WE HAVE A SHORTAGE OF
ENGINEERS NAY COUNTY ABOUT. WE
WILL FIND SOMEONE TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE AN ENGINEER
AVAILABLE TO AND WORK WITH CITY
ENGINEERS COMING FROM LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. I'M SURE WE CAN
SPREAD THE RESOURCES AND MAKE
SURE WE HAVE IT COVERED. GOOD
ENOUGH. VERY GOOD THANK YOU
THANK YOU SEE NO FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. POINT OF
ORDER YES CENTER SKINNER. I
JUST WANTED TO. INDICATE THAT I
DON'T BELIEVE OUR ON SENATOR
PRESENTING WOULD BE REQUIRED TO
RESPOND FROM THE QUESTION BY
OUR GOOD SENATOR FROM MANHATTAN
BEACH SANTA MONICA BECAUSE- THE
SENATOR REFERENCED DEBATE. AND
THERE'S NOT DEBATE ON THE FLOOR.
POINT POINT WELL TAKEN GONZALEZ
IF YOU COULD CLOSE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR THE AYE
VOTE THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
QUESTION STRONG CLOSE VERY GOOD.
WITH THAT MISTER SECRETARY
ALWAYS ACT ACTUALLY BELIEVE OR
NOT DESPITE ALL THE DEBATE THIS
IS A CANDIDATE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL SO I'M GOING TO RISK
IT. AND SAY. ANY OBJECTIONS TO
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL BOYS IN THE
CORNER THERE NO OKAY WITH THAT.
MEASURE ICE FORTY KNOWS HERE
ZERO MEASURE PASSES
CONGRATULATIONS CENTER GONZALEZ.
OKAY MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM TO
THIRTY FOUR CENTER PORTANTINO
ARE YOU PREPARED. AS YOU ALWAYS
ARE WITH THAT MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL TEN
OH NINE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GABRIEL AND ACTUALLY TO
FIREARMS. THERE PORTANTINO
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT
AB ONE THOUSAND NINE ON BEHALF
OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER JESSE
GABRIEL THE BILL MODERNIZE IS
THE STATE'S FIREARM
REGISTRATION PROCESS SAVES
TAXPAYERS RESOURCES AND
INSURERS LAW ENFORCEMENT HAS
ACCESS TO ACCURATE AND RELIABLE
GUN REGISTRATION DATA. THE DOJ
HAS FOUND THEM IN OVER IN THE
OVERWHELMING MAJORITY OF
REQUIRED FIREARM REGISTRATIONS
ARE BEING SUBMITTED VIA MAIL
MAIL IN FORMS CAN BE DIFFICULT
TO READ TAKE LONGER FOR THE DOJ
TO PROCESS AND ARE MUCH MORE
EXPENSIVE. IN RESPONSE AB ONE
THOUSAND NINE ADDRESS THE
FIREARM REGISTRATION PROCESS TO
ALLOW THE DOJ TO PLACE A
REASONABLE SURCHARGE ON MAIL IN
REGISTRATION FORMS. THIS
REPRESENTS THE ADDITIONAL COST
OF RECEIVING AND PROCESSING THE
REPORT AND INSURERS OF THE DOJ
HAS THE RESOURCES THEY NEED TO
PROCESS REGISTRATION FORMS IN A
TIMELY AND EFFICIENT MANNER
SUPPORT
OPPOSITION AND RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU SIR.
SEEING NO FURTHER DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION MISTER SECRETARY
CALL THE ROLL ALLEN. I
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE BATES.
BELL I PURCHASED BRADFORD HI
KELLY AT ALL I CHIANG I DALY
DODD I DORADO I GALGIANI I
GLAZER I GONZALEZ I GROWTH.
HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO BY
TITLE I JACKSON I JONES NO
LEYVA. BY MCGUIRE I MITCHELL BY
MONEY I'M MORE LUCK HIGH MORALE
NO NIELSEN. I PAN AYE
PORTANTINO. I ROTH AYE RUBIO
AYE SKINNER I STERN BY STONE.
NO NUMBER IRA CASKEY AYE WIENER
AYE WILK HI. MISTER SECRETARY
CALLED ABSENT MEMBERS BATES.
BURGESS DALY GROWTH. SIZE
THIRTY THREE KNOWS THREE
MEASURE PASSES MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM TWO FIFTY NINE.
CENTER BARGES LOOKS LIKE HE'S
PREPARED TO MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
THREE TWENTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER PATTERSON ENACT
WILLING TO TAXATION TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY TAX LEVY
CENTER BARGES THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT I RISE TO PRESENT A.
B. THIRTY TWO EIGHT A. B. THREE
TWO ONE ON BEHALF OF SOMEONE
PATTERSON. THIS BILL SEEKS TO
BRING PARITY TO THE LAW
REGARDING TAXATION FOR
COMMERCIAL TRUCKS AND TRAILERS
USED INTERSTATE COMMERCE
CURRENTLY FOR A COMMERCIAL
TRUCK PERSON CALIFORNIA TO
QUALIFY AS INTERSTATE COMMERCE
FOR TAX PURPOSES IT MUST MEET
TO QUALIFICATIONS MUST BE OUT
OF THE STATE MORE THAN 50% THE
TIME IN THE VEHICLE MUST MAKE
ITS INITIAL TRIP. WITH A LOAD
INTO THE STATE EVEN IF WAS
ALREADY PURCHASED IN CALIFORNIA
MANDATING THIS INBOUND TRIP
REQUIREMENT INCREASES POLLUTION
AND DISCOURAGES BUYERS FROM
PURCHASING THEIR COMMERCIAL
TRUCKS IN CALIFORNIA. CURRENTLY
COMMERCIAL TRAILERS PERCHED IN
THE STATE IN USED INTERSTATE
COMMERCE. DO NOT NEED TO MEET
THIS INBOUND TRIP REQUIREMENT
BUT SIMPLY MOSTLY THE STATE
WITHIN SEVENTY FIVE DAYS A. B.
THREE TWO ONE WILL APPLY THE
SAME REQUIREMENTS TO COMMERCIAL
VEHICLES PURCHASED IN
CALIFORNIA FOR THE PURPOSE OF
INTERSTATE COMMERCE THIS BILL
HAS NO OPPOSITION AND PASSED
OUT OF THE ASSEMBLY WITH
OVERWHELMING BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT. I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
I VOTE. THANK YOU SIR BARGES
THREE NO FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE THIS THIS BILL IS A
CANDID FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
ANY OBJECTIONS. DULY NOTED
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALLEN. ARCHULETA I
ATKINS. I BATES HI BILL HI
GORGEOUS. BY BRADFORD I
CAMBIADO I CHIANG I DALY I DODD.
BY THE RISE OF I GALGIANI. I
GLAZER I GONZALEZ. I GROWTH I
HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO
AYE OR TITLE HI. JACKSON HI
JONES. BY LEYVA I MCGUIRE I AM
MITCHELL. BY MORNING I'M MORE
LOCK. I'M A REAL AYE NIELSEN
AYE PAN AYE PORTANTINO. BY ROTH
AYE RUBIO AYE SKINNER AYE STERN
BY STONE. I AM BURKE I WOULD
COUNTY. I WINNER BY WILK HI HI.
MISTER SECRETARY CALLED THE
ABSENT MEMBER ALLEN. FIVE
THIRTY NINE NO ZERO MEASURE
PASSES. MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
TO SIXTY TWO SENATOR RUBIO
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX OH FIVE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN AN
ACT RELATING TO SPECIAL
EDUCATION CENTER RUBIO THANK
YOU MISTER PRESIDENT TODAY I
RISE TO PRESENT AB SIX OH FIVE
THERE WILL ENSURE THAT STUDENTS
REQUIRING ASSISTIVE TECHNOLOGY
THE VICE HAVE THE RIGHT TO USE
THE DEVICE OUTSIDE OF SCHOOL
HOURS. IF DETERMINE NECESSARY
BY THEIR INDIVIDUALIZED
EDUCATION PROGRAM KNOWN AS IP
THIS BILL ALSO ALLOWS THE
STUDENT TO TAKE THEIR ASSISTIVE
TECHNOLOGY DEVICES WITH THEM
UPON TRANSFER TWENTY SCHOOL FOR
UP TO TWO MONTHS TO ENSURE A%
SEAMLESS TRANSITION TO A NEW
SCHOOL THIS DEVICE IS VERY
IMPORTANT TOOL FOR STUDENTS
WITH SPECIAL NEEDS TO
COMMUNICATE LEARN AND INTERACT
IN THEIR ENVIRONMENT CURRENTLY
SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN CALIFORNIA
ALLOW USAGE OF THESE DEVICES.
HOWEVER MANY OF THEM ONLY ALLOW
THEM TO BE USED AT THE
DESIGNATED INSTITUTION AND
DURING SCHOOL HOURS HAVING
THESE DEVICES WITH THEM AT ALL
TIMES INSURERS A STUDENT ALWAYS
HOUSE THEIR VOICE AND ALLOWS
THE STUDENT AND PARENTS TO
CONTINUE THEIR LEARNING AT HOME
AS WELL. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR RIVAL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR RUBIO. EXCUSE ME ANY
FURTHER DEBATER DISCUSSION.
THING NINE THIS IS A CANDIDATE
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. OKAY
WE DO HAVE ONE SO MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN. I ARE SO LETTER BY
ATKINS. BY BATES HI BILL I
BRIDGES I BRADFORD I CABALLERO
I CHIANG I DALY BY DODD BY THE
RUSSELL. I GALGIANI BY GLAZER
BY GONZALEZ BY GROW. I
HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO HI
TITLE. HI JACKSON BY JONES I
LEYVA BY MCGUIRE HI MITCHELL HI
MONNING I'M MORE LUCK I'M REAL.
NIELSEN. I PAN AYE PORTANTINO
AYE ROTH AYE RUBIO I SKINNER.
BY STERN AYE STONE. I HAMBURG
ADVOCACY BY WIENER BY WILK HI.
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS MORRELL.
ICE THIRTY NINE NO ZERO MEASURE
PASSES RETURNING THE PRIVILEGES
OF THE FLOOR SENATOR RUBIO.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
TODAY FIRST OF ALL I RISE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE OUR COLLEAGUE FROM
LONG BEACH WHO GOT MARRIED THIS
PAST WEEKEND AND IS THE FIRST
TIME BACK AS MRS ADAM CURRY
YOU'LL SO LET'S CONGRATULATE.
HER THERE IS A GOD THAT. MRS
ADAM CURRY I HAPPENED TO ATTEND
THE WEDDING AND IT WAS REALLY A
VERY OVELY SO. I ALSO WANT TO
THANK HER BECAUSE SHE INSPIRED.
ANOTHER LOVE STORY THERE'S
ANOTHER ENGAGEMENT ON THIS
FLOOR. SO PLEASE HELP ME
CONGRATULATE OUR GOOD FRIEND
FROM CANOGA PARK MISTER HENRY
STERN WHO JUST GOT ENGAGED OVER
THE WEEKEND. TO HIS LOVELY
FIANCE ALEXANDRA SO
CONGRATULATIONS TO ALEXANDER
MISTER STARR AND
CONGRATULATIONS ALTHOUGH I TOLD
THEM THAT WE NEEDED TO BRING IT
TO THE FLOOR FOR A VOTE HE DID
AND THAT'S AND HE VETOED THAT
IDEA SO CONGRATULATIONS. TO
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS THIS IS
APPROPRIATE TIME TO DO TO DO
JOURNEY IN MEMORIES. AND WITH
THAT LIKE TO INVITE SENATOR
UMBERG. WHICH. BAKER MIND
EVERYBODY TO SHOW RESPECT BY.
REMAINING IN YOUR SEATS. YOU
READY. CENTER NUMBER OF THE
FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT AND COLLEAGUES IT IS
MY PRIVILEGE TO BE ABLE TO ASK
THAT WE ADJOURN IN MEMORY. OF
PICKLER TODAY. IF THE GREATEST
GENERATION HAD ONE EXAMPLE IT
WOULD BE PICKLER EARTH PICKLER
FLEW THIRTY FIVE COMBAT
MISSIONS IN WHAT WAR TO. HIS
WIFE BETTY THEY STAYED MARRIED
FOR OVER SEVENTY YEARS UNTIL
HER PASSING. HE WAS THE KIND OF
PERSON WHO MADE IS PERSONAL
RESPONSIBILITY TO IMPROVE THE
COMMUNITY HE SERVED ON MULTIPLE
NONPROFIT BOARDS ON THE ORANGE
COUNTY WATER DISTRICT BOARD THE
AND I'M HEART ASSOCIATION BOARD
THE AND I'M FAMILY YMCA BOARD
THE QANTAS CLUB GREATER AN ON
BOARD. HE ALSO WAS A PLANNING
COMMISSIONER HE ALSO WAS A
SCHOOL BOARD MEMBER HE ALSO WAS
A CITY COUNCIL MEMBER. WHAT IS
MOST IMPORTANT. HIS MOST
IMPORTANT FEET IN LIFE WAS
BEING A WONDERFUL FATHER TO HIS
FIVE CHILDREN AND BEING A
SUPERB GRAND FATHER AND HUSBAND
HE IS SURVIVED BY HIS FIVE
CHILDREN DON MARSHA SCOTT ELLEN
AND BRAD SEVERAL OF THEM
BASEBALL COACHES IT'S THREE
DOES COLLEGE HE WAS A
TREMENDOUS FAN OF THREE DOES
COLLEGE BASEBALL END OF THE
ANGELS AND WILL BE SORELY
MISSED BY ALL OF US IN THE
ORANGE COUNTY COMMUNITY. AND I
ASKED THAT WE ADJOURN HIS
MEMORY TODAY THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT THANK YOU FOR THAT
EXTEND OUR CONDOLENCES TO THE
PARTICULAR FAMILY SENATOR JONES.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO HONOR
KALIFORNIA FIREFIGHTER.
YAROSLAV YARO CAT BECAUSE OF.
WHO DIED LAST MONTH AFTER
SUFFERING A MEDICAL EMERGENCY
WHILE TRAINING WITH HIS ENGINE
COMPANY. WE SAY GOODBYE TO YOUR
WHO LONG DREAMT OF A CAREER
PROTECTING HIS FELLOW CITIZENS
FROM HARM. WE ARE CAME TO THE
UNITED STATES FROM UKRAINE WITH
WITH HIS FAMILY AS A CHILD.
LEARNED ENGLISH. GRADUATED FROM
COLLEGE AND ACHIEVE HIS DREAM
OF BECOMING A FIREFIGHTER. IN
SCHOOL YARO WAS AN ACTIVE
ATHLETE AND PARTICIPATED IN
SEVERAL SPORTS INCLUDING
FOOTBALL. TRACK AND WRESTLING
AND WON THE SAN DIEGO CITY
WRESTLING CHAMPIONSHIP. UPON
GRADUATING FROM HIGH SCHOOL
YARO ATTENDED SAN DIEGO STATE
UNIVERSITY ANTENNA BASS SORT
BACHELOR'S DEGREE IN FINANCE.
WITH A DESIRE TO SERVE OTHERS
ZERO WAS HIRED BY CAL FIRE SAN
DIEGO IN AUGUST OF TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN. AND SHOWED HIMSELF TO
BE A MAN OF INTEGRITY AND
PROFESSIONALISM. EXEMPLIFY THE
CHARACTER WE SEE SO COMMONLY IN
THE BRAVE INDIVIDUALS WHO PUT
THEIR LIVES ON THE LINE TAKING
ON THE PERILOUS DUTIES OF FIRE
PREVENTION AND SUPPRESSION.
HERE IN CALIFORNIA. HE AND HE
WAS RENOWNED AMONG HIS FELLOW
FIREFIGHTERS REPEAT FOR BEING
DEDICATED TO HIS FAMILY. THE
UNIFORM AND THE FIRE SERVICE
COMMUNITY. YOUR LEASE BEHIND
HIS GIRLFRIEND ASHLEY HIS
PARENTS IGOR AND NADIA HIS
BROTHER SAM AND HIS ENTIRE FIRE
SERVICE FAMILY. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK ASK TODAY THAT THE SENATE
ADJOURNED IN MEMORY I HAVE
JAROSLAW CAT BECAUSE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS. THEY KEEP THANK YOU
CENTER JONES AND EXTEND OUR
SYMPATHIES WHILE SENATOR
HERTZBERG. THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT. DURING THE RECESS. I
LOST ONE OF MY CLOSEST FRIENDS
AND A MENTOR. NAME IS HENRY
LOZANO HE WAS A MARINE. IS
EIGHTY FIVE YEARS OLD WHEN HE
DIED. AND THIRTIES LIVED A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY. HE WAS ONE
OF THOSE KINDS OF PEOPLE THAT
PROBABLY EACH OF US KNOW WHEN
COMMUNITIES THAT WE REPRESENT
EXPERIENCES THAT WE HAD THAT
NEVER MADE THE NEWSPAPERS. BUT
ALWAYS HAD JUST AN
EXTRAORDINARY IMPACT ON THE
COMMUNITY WE CALLED HIM THE
GODFATHER OF THESE DE LA THE
GODFATHER BECAUSE HE TOOK
EVERYBODY UNDER HIS WING AND
TOOK CARE OF EVERYBODY HE
LAUNCHED MORE CAREERS HELP MORE
PEOPLE WHO GET IN OFFICE. A IN
THE LATINO COMMUNITY THAT I
THINK ANYONE I KNOW MAYBE
RICHARD POLANCO IS TIED WITH
HIM BUT I'M NOT SO SURE CENTER
POLANCO. HE WAS THE CHIEF OF
STAFF TO CONGRESS AND ROY BALL.
WHO WAS ELECTED TO THE CITY
COUNCIL IN NINETEEN FORTY NINE
LOS ANGELES TO THE CONGRESS IN
NINETEEN SIXTY TWO. AND WE
CALLED CONGRESS AND ROY BALL
THE CONGRESSMAN BECAUSE IT WAS
ONLY ONE LEFT YOU KNOW
CONGRESSMAN. IN THE UNITED
STATES CONGRESS. WE HE WAS
INSTRUMENTAL IN A STEP ON
TORRANCE WE CALL THE MEATY
GETTING ELECTED HE CHAIRED AND
WAS INVOLVED WITH ME WITH HOW
THE ADDRESS THAT I WHEN HE RAN
FOR. THE ASSEMBLY IN NINETEEN
NINETY AND CHOSE NOT TO RUN FOR
CONGRESS IN SUPPORT OF HOW THE
AD IN NINETEEN NINETY TWO IS
NOW OUR ATTORNEY GENERAL. HE
WAS THERE FOR GLORIA MOLINA FOR
LUCILLE ROYBAL ALLARD FOR CITY
COUNCILMAN MIKE HERNANDEZ FOR
CITY COUNCILMAN NICK BUT CZECHO
FOR OUR TAURUS FOR. RICHARD
ALATORRE. HE WAS JUST A FOR
HILL THE SO LEASE IN OUR FIRST
ELECTION TO THE RIO HATO
COMMUNITY COLLEGE BOARD OF
TRUSTEES WHICH I WORKED ON. AS
A RESULT OF THE PRESSURE OF THE
GREAT GODFATHER HENRY LOZANO.
HE TOOK CARE OF EVERYBODY HE
CARE DEEPLY ABOUT THE COMMUNITY.
LIFE WAS INFORMED. BY IS YOUNG
UPBRINGING IN TEXAS WAS A THIRD
GENERATION TO HANDLE AND HE WAS
FORCED TO GO TO A LOT THE ONLY
SCHOOL INTO A SPECIFIC SCHOOL
CAUSES SKIN WAS DARKER. HE IS
INFORMED AS A FELLOW WHO'S
ALWAYS FOUGHT FOR PEOPLE WHO
THE UNDERDOG WHO SOUGHT THE
POWER OF THE POWERLESS. AND
AGAIN HE WAS NOT SOMEONE WHO
MADE THE FRONT PAGE OF THE
NEWSPAPER BUT SOMEONE WHO MADE
PEOPLE ON THE FRONT PAGE OF THE
NEWSPAPER AND INFORMED AND
BROUGHT THE LATINO COMMUNITY IN
JUST IT BROUGHT UP. IN
POLITICALLY IN SO MANY RACES
AND JUST WENT TO WAR FOR FOLKS
IT'S BEEN A FRIEND OF MINE
SINCE NINETEEN SEVENTY THREE
WHEN I WAS LITTLE PIPS SQUEAK
AND HE TOOK ME UNDER HIS ARMS
THINKING I WAS LATINO I GUESS.
BUT IT WORKED. SO IN ANY EVENT
WE LOST HIM AND WE LOST A GREAT
GREAT RESOURCE FOR CALIFORNIA
SOMEONE WHOSE SHOULDERS WE ALL
STAND ON SOMEONE WHO I DEEPLY
RESPECT. AND SOMEONE WHO WE ALL
GREAT RESPECT TO ASK THE SENATE
ADJOURNED IT IS MEMORY. THE
THIRD DROUGHT SO ARE YOU COMING
ON MISTER YES IS ON OKAY THINGS.
PLEASE THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I JUST WANT TO ADD
OF THAT ONE OF THE- THE WAY
THAT MISTER LOZANO GOT INVOLVED
WITH THAT AFTER HE CAME BACK
FROM. THE SERVICE AFTER HE WAS
DISCHARGED YOU WANT TO WORK AT
AN EAST OF EAST SIDE AEROSPACE
PLANT WILL STUDY MACHINERY AT
ELLIE TRADE TECH COLLEGE UP IT
WAS THROUGH THE LABOR MOVEMENT
THROUGH THE- AUTO WORKERS
UNION. THAT HE ACTUALLY BECAME
INVOLVED IN POLITICS AND THEN
BECAME THE PERSON THAT HE IS
ALWAYS I THINK THOSE WITH HIS
ROOTS IN TERMS OF ALWAYS
STANDING UP FOR THE WORKING MAN
AND WOMAN SO I ALSO ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT. GREAT THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR THAT. CENTER
GONZALEZ. IT IS WITH GREAT
SADNESS THAT I ASKED WE
ADJOURNED IN MEMORY OF A DEAR
FRIEND OF MINE AND LONG TIME
DEMOCRATIC ACTIVISTS AND
COMMUNITY MEMBER FROM LONG
BEACH AND A SODA. ANNA PASSED
AWAY ON JULY TWENTY SIX THIS OF
THIS YEAR AND IS SURVIVED BY
HER HUSBAND REGGIE AND THREE
BROTHERS TOM MIKE PATRICK.
ALONG WITH MANY OTHER FAMILY
MEMBERS FOR ALL OF THOSE WHO
DID NOT KNOW HER AND I WAS A
STRONG AT SPOKE IN AN AMAZING
WOMAN WHO CARED DEEPLY FOR
POLITICS AND THE COMMUNITY. SHE
WAS THE DAUGHTER OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PHIL SO TO ONE OF THE
FIRST LATINOS ELECTED TO THE
STATE LEGISLATURE. AND SENATOR
NOW ALSO TO THE FIRST LATINA
FROM THE SAN GABRIEL VALLEY
ELECTED TO THE SENATE. BOTH OF
ANNA'S PARENTS DEDICATED MANY
YEARS OF PUBLIC SERVICE TO THE
CITIZENS AND RESIDENTS OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE TAUGHT HER
THE IMPORTANCE OF FIGHTING FOR
PROGRESSIVE IDEALS AND THE
COMMUNITY. AND HELP PAVE THE
WAY FOR ANNA AND OTHER LEADERS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. AND IT
WAS A DRIVEN INCOMPETENT LEADER
IN HER CAREER AS A POLICY
ANALYST FOR LOS ANGELES COUNTY
WORKING ON HER VERY IMPORTANT
PASSION. TO COMBAT HUMAN
TRAFFICKING. AS WELL AS SERVING
AS A PROMINENT VOICE AS THE
SIXTY THIRD ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
DELEGATE CHAIR UNTIL HER
PASSING. SHE NEVER HESITATED TO
GUIDE AND MENTOR LEADERS
INCLUDING MYSELF AND I KNOW WE
WILLALL TRULY MISS HER. NOT
ONLY IN LONG BEACH BUT IN THE
ALLEY COUNTY REGION. HER
POSITIVE ENERGY HONESTY AND
STRENGTH AS WHY ASK FOR US TO
ADJOURN IN MEMORY FOR A AND A
SODA. THANK YOU. THANK YOU IN
EXTEND OUR CONDOLENCES TO THE
FAMILY. WE'RE GONNA HAVE
SENATOR ROTH AND SENATOR STONED.
WITH ON REGARDING CHP OFFICER
MORESO WILL START WITH YOU
SENATOR ROCK. THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT. MONDAY AUGUST
TWELFTH TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN A
DEADLY STARTED JUST LIKE ANY
OTHER DAY FOR THIRTY FOUR YEAR
OLD OFFICER ANDRE MORLEY. HE
LEFT HIS HOME IN MARINO VALLEY
PROBABLY GAVE HIS BRIDE OF
THREE YEARS SIR KISS OR A HUG.
CLIMBED ON HIS MOTORCYCLE AND
STARTED TO SHIFT AS A MOTOR
OFFICER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
HIGHWAY PATROL. HE MAY HAVE
EVEN CALLED HIS PARENTS HIS
STEPFATHER OR ONE OR MORE OF
HIS FIVE BROTHERS AND SISTERS.
TO TALK ABOUT HIS LIFE AND HIS
JOB. IN FACT HE WAS FULL OF
LIFE. AND IT WAS A JOB HE LOVED
HE REFERRED TO IT AS HIS DREAM
JOB RIDING THE MOTORCYCLE THAT
HE LOVED AND SERVING OTHERS IN
A WAY THAT HE LOVED. OTHERS
LOVE HIM TO IN FACT THEY SAY HE
HAD A BIG HEART. AND IT SHOWED.
LATER THAT SAME DAY AT
APPROXIMATELY FIVE THIRTY FIVE
PM WHILE PATROLLING THE TWO
FIFTEEN FREEWAY IN THE VICINITY
OF RIVERSIDE. OFFICER VOICE BY
THE SPOTTED A WHITE PICKUP
TRUCK WITH A SINGLE OCCUPANT
DRIVING IN THE CAR POOL LANE.
HE INITIATED A TRAFFIC STOP BUT
THE EAST RIDGE INTERSECTION.
THE DRIVER APPARENTLY HAD
EXPIRED DRIVER'S LICENSE AND NO
CURRENT VEHICLE REGISTRATION.
OFFICER MORE DETERMINED BUT THE
PICKUP NOT PICK UP TRUCK NEEDED
TO BE IMPOUNDED AND HE BEGAN TO
INITIATE THE IMPASSE POUND. AS
HE DID SO. THE DRIVER GRABBED
THE NAY ARE FIFTEEN STYLE RIFLE
FROM THE TRUCK AND STARTED
FIRING AT OFFICER MORE.
ALTHOUGH MORTALLY WOUNDED BY
THE FIRE OFFICER MORE MANAGED
TO RETURN FIRE HAS HE CALLED
FOR BACKUP. MANY LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS RESPONDED
TO THAT CALL AND ACCORDING TO
OUR RIVERSIDE. CHIEF OF POLICE
SERGIO DE AS THE GUN BATTLE WAS
LONG AND HORRIFIC. A GUN BATTLE
FRANKLY WITNESSED BY ONE OF MY
OWN DISTRICT STAFF ON HIS WAY
HOME IN HIS CAR STOPPED AT THAT
SAME EASTRIDGE INTERSECTION.
TWO OF THE CHP OFFICERS WHO
RESPONDED TO THE CALL FOR HELP
WERE WOUNDED ONE CRITICALLY.
WELL THEY BOTH SURVIVED THAT
DAY TRAGICALLY OFFICER MAURY
DID NOT. NOW OF THE DRIVER OF
THE PICKUP WHO WAS KILLED
DURING THE GUN BATTLE WAS A
CONVICTED FELON. SOMEONE WHO
SERVED HIS TIME. BUT WAS NOT
LEGALLY PERMITTED TO OWN A
FIREARM. HIS RIFLE REPORTEDLY
WAS A GHOST GUN. THE FIRM
ASSEMBLED FROM PARTS NOT A
WEAPON PURCHASE FROM A GUN
STORE OR AT A GUN SHOW. BUT
EVERY BIT AS DEADLY. FRANKLY A
WEAPON AND PARTS THE DRIVER
SHOULD NEVER HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
ACQUIRE. THE TRAGEDY HERE OF
COURSE IS THAT HE DID. AND THAT
HE AMBUSHED OFFICER MOORE WHO
WAS SIMPLY ATTEMPTING TO DO HIS
JOB. TO ENFORCE THE LAW. AND TO
PROTECT ALL OF THE REST OF US.
NO IT'S A VERY VERY DANGEROUS
JOB THAT THESE OFFICERS HAVE
DEALING WITH PEOPLE DOING
THINGS THEY SHOULDN'T BE DOING
FACING PEOPLE WHO POSSESS
THINGS THEY'RE NOT SUPPOSED TO
POSSESS AND YET THESE OFFICERS
REPORT TO THEIR POSTS. AND STAY
ON THEIR WATCH. UP AND DOWN OUR
STATE EVERY DAY. NOW I WONDER
HOW MANY TIMES DURING THE YEAR
WHEN WE EACH OF US SEE A PEACE
OFFICER ON THE STREET IN A
PATROL CAR ON A MOTORCYCLE OR
EVEN IN THIS VERY BUILDING THAT
WE TAKE THAT OFFICER AND HIS OR
HER ROLE. FOR GRANTED AT BEST.
WELL RECENT EVENTS IN OHIO AND
STATES AROUND THIS COUNTRY
INCLUDING THIS ONE DEMONSTRATE
THAT THEY DON'T TAKE OUR SAFETY
FOR GRANTED. EVER AND THAT WAS
CERTAINLY THE CASE WITH OFFICER
MORE. OFFICER. ANDRE MORE
JUNIOR END OF WATCH AUGUST
TWELFTH TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
MAY HE REST IN PEACE. THANK YOU
CENTER ROTH SENATOR STONE THANK
YOU COLLEAGUES AND I JOIN MY
COLLEAGUE AND FRIEND FROM
RIVERSIDE TO ADJOURN IN THE
MEMORY OF AND MORE A- WHO IS A
PROUD CHP OFFICER WHO WAS
MURDERED ON MONDAY. BY A CAREER
CRIMINAL. WHO SHOULD NEVER BEEN
LET OUT OF JAIL IN THE FIRST
PLACE. THAT IS TOO OFTEN THE
CASE OFFICER MOREY'S DEATH
STARTED WITH THE SO CALLED
ROUTINE TRAFFIC STOP. HE PULLED
OVER THE MURDERS TRUCK IN
RIVERSIDE AND STARTED FILLING
OUT PAPERWORK TO IMPOUND THE
VEHICLE. THAT'S WHEN OFFICER
MORE HIS LIFE WAS STRIPPED AWAY
FROM HIS FRIENDS HIS FAMILY HIS
LOVED ONES. WHEN UP FROM WHERE
HE WAS FILLING OUT THE
PAPERWORK THE KILLER REACHED
INSIDE THE VEHICLE IMPLIED A
RIFLE. AND SHOT OFFICER MORE A.
THANKFULLY FOR THE OTHER
POTENTIAL VICTIMS A CH P. HERO
WAS ABLE TO GET TO HIS RADIO
LET THE OTHER OFFICERS KNOW
THAT HE NEEDED ASSISTANCE. THAT
CALL. MORE RESULTING IN TWO
MORE OFFICERS BEING WOUNDED IN
THE LINK THEY SHOOT OUT.
PROBABLY SAVED INNOCENT LIVES.
SHOT BY ASSISTING LAW
ENFORCEMENT PERSONNEL. WHAT IS
ESPECIALLY TRAGIC ABOUT THIS
MURDER IS IT IT DIDN'T HAVE TO
HAPPEN. OFF THE MORTGAGE KILLER
WAS A CAREER CRIMINAL WITH A
VIOLENT HISTORY. IF YOU WERE
KEPT IN PRISON WHERE HE
BELONGED OFFICER MAURY WAS
STILL BE ALIVE DOING ALL THE
GOOD THINGS THAT HE DID TO KEEP
CALIFORNIA SAFE. MY WIFE GOES
OUT TO HIS WIFE SARAH IN THIS
FAMILY WHO LOST A HUSBAND. AND
THE SUN I CAN ONLY SAY THAT
OFFICER MORE A WAS A HERO. HE
WAS A FRIEND TO MANY IN A
PUBLIC SERVANT TO ALL OF US. I
LOOK FORWARD TO JOINING MY
COLLEAGUE IN RIVERSIDE IN THE
SECOND YEAR OF THE SESSION. TO
PROBABLY MEMORIALIZES NAME ON A
SECTION OF STATE HIGHWAY.
PLEASE JOIN ME TODAY IN IT
JOINING THE MEMORY OF OFFICER
WILL ENTER MAURY HE WILL ALWAYS
BE REMEMBERED IT WILL NEVER BE
FORGOTTEN BY THE PEOPLE THAT
HELP CONSERVE MAY REST IN PEACE.
THANK YOU CENTER STONE EXTEND
OUR CONDOLENCES TO THE MORE A
FAMILY SENATOR STERN. THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT. ARISE ON A.
NO LESS A SAD OCCASION BUT IS
SLIGHTLY LESS TRAGIC NOTICE
SOMEONE WHO LIVED A LONG AND
FULL LIFE. AND WASN'T STOLEN
FROM US THE SAME WAY WE JUST
HEARD FROM OUR COLLEAGUES. DOWN
SOUTH ARISE TO JOURNEY MEMORY.
OF A SURFING LEGEND IN THE SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY AND THE MALIBU
REGION GLENN KENNEDY. SURFBOARD
SHAPER WHO'S BEEN A FIXTURE
SINCE NINETEEN SEVENTY TWO WHEN
HE OPENED KENNEDY SURF SHOP.
THE THING IN OUR NECK OF THE
WOODS THERE'S A TENSION WITH
THE VALLEY IN THE COAST WHERE
SOMETIMES OTHER PEOPLE ON THE
COAST MAKE THOSE IN THE VALLEY
FEEL UNWELCOME THAT THEY'RE NOT.
ENTITLED TO ENJOY THE RESOURCES
OF THE BEACH SHORT TO SURF
THERE BUT GLENN BROKE THROUGH
THOSE BARRIERS. AND MADE
EVERYBODY FEEL WELCOME GLENN
WAS NOT ONLY A PREMIER SHAPER
BUT A MENTOR. HE WASN'T JUST. A
BUSINESSMAN OR OR A DOLLARS AND
CENTS GUY HE KNEW ABOUT
COMMUNITY IN HISTORY. DURING A
BUSY DATE OFTEN TAKE TIME TO
EDUCATE CUSTOMERS AND FRIENDS
ABOUT THE HISTORY OF SURFING
FROM THE SAN FERNANDO VALLEY.
AND HE WAS DEDICATED THE BELIEF
THAT SURFING IS FOR EVERYBODY
NOT JUST FOR THE SELECT FEW
ACTUALLY GET TO LIVE NEAR THAT
BEACH. AFTER HIS PASSING
HUNDRED THE GLENS FRIENDS.
PADDLED OUT IN MALIBU IN HIS
MEMORY A BEAUTIFUL
DEMONSTRATION JUST HOW MANY
LIVES HE TOUCHED. HE IS
SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE BARBARA IS
SON LEE AND DAUGHTERS NO WELL
IN THE COAL. RESPECTFULLY ASK
THAT WE OFFER OUR SINCEREST
CONDOLENCES TO HIS FAMILY IN A
TURN IN HIS MEMORY. THANK YOU
CENTER STERN ANY OTHER
ADJOURNED ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY. SEEING NONE. IF THERE'S
NO OTHER BUSINESS SENATOR
ATKINS THE DESK IS CLEAR. YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT. YOU
COLLEAGUES FOR THE WORK TODAY
WE WILL RECONVENE ON THURSDAY
AUGUST TWENTY SECOND TWENTY
NINETEEN AT NINE AM. THANK YOU
MEMBERS AGAIN THE SENATE WILL
BE ADJOURNED AND WE'LL
RECONVENE HERE ON THURSDAY AT
NINE AM